So, heute Five-Head-Time, Leute.
Wir benchmarken heute mal ein paar Sachen.
Und zwar...
Ich zeige euch das, bevor ich jetzt lange erzähle.
Wir haben ja auch im Stream schon ein bisschen mit Web...
Ich muss mal ein bisschen leiser machen.
Heute schon gesportet? Ja, heute moin.
Allerdings...
Die Lautstärke kann sich mal wieder nicht entscheiden.
Okay.
Aber heute nur 5,56 Kilometer.
Nicht wieder 10 plus wie letzten Sonntag.
Also ganz normale Runde, die ich sonst auch renne.
Naja, wobei nicht exakt die gleiche.
Meine normale Runde 6,2.
Ich mach schon mal meine VM an.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal, bevor es losgeht...
Ich zeige euch jetzt, was wir machen.
Und...
Dann futtere ich nochmal zwei Plätzchen, die ich mitgebracht habe hier gerade.
Aber in der Zwischenzeit können wir nochmal ein Package-Update auf der VM machen, falls es das in der Zwischenzeit schon gegeben hat.
Weil ich glaube, zuletzt haben wir heute Morgen geupdatet.
Also, ich zeige euch, was wir heute machen.
Ich glaube, das wird recht spannend, zumindest interessieren mich die Ergebnisse auch.
Und zwar, wir rufen heute von C-Sharp aus sowohl Rust-Funktionen auf, als auch Go-Funktionen.
Was liegt daran?
Ihr könnt euch vielleicht noch dran erinnern.
Ich hab im Stream ja schon öfters mal ein bisschen mit WebRTC auf Serverseite rumgebastelt.
Zum Beispiel, dass man sich connecten kann in den Browser und dann Webcams abspielen und solche Geschichten.
Also ich hab ja schon öfters mal ein bisschen mit WebRTC rumgebastelt.
Und ich hab die letzten Tage über mal so ein bisschen Just for Fun wieder ein bisschen rumgebaut mit WebRTC.
Also WebRTC ist quasi Real-Time Video im Browser.
Nicht Streaming, wohlgemerkt nicht Streaming.
Also Streaming ist ja meistens HLS.
Also HLS ist, was heißt das?
Für was steht HLS eigentlich?
Gute Frage.
HTTP-Live-Streaming.
Okay.
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Also die ganzen Streaming-Seiten, die funktionieren meistens über HLS.
HLS ist relativ easy.
HLS gibt es eine M3U8-Datei.
Und da stehen dann URLs drin, die rotatet werden.
Und alle paar Sekunden gibt es da einen neuen Eintrag drin.
Und dann streamt das.
Also es macht ab und zu mal ein Get und dann holt sich so ein 5-Sekunden-Häppchen vom Stream.
Und dann macht es wieder ein Get neues 5-Sekunden-Häppchen.
WebRTC ist tatsächlich Real-Time.
On-End-Gerät zu End-Gerät.
Das ist besonders gut, wenn man möglichst Latency-Free-Video haben will.
Was cool ist für Audio-Calls.
Also beispielsweise Microsoft Teams und sowas.
Das läuft nach Möglichkeiten über WebRTC.
Und halt auch für Videokameras.
Wenn man zum Beispiel drauf gucken will, wer vor der Tür steht und sowas.
Und das möglichst Latency-Free sehen will alles.
Dann ist WebRTC gut.
Aber das machen wir heute nicht.
Ich sag nur, wie ich drauf gekommen bin.
Und ich verwende für...
Oh, ich habe irgendwas im Auge.
Das ist ja super abartig.
Razer, danke für den Sub.
Und by the way, wir installieren gerade mal die neue JetBrains IDE für Rust.
Erstmal hier updaten.
Die Toolbox darf auch updaten.
Genau, und normalerweise habe ich das immer mit dieser Library hier gemacht.
Und die ist in Go.
Die ist in Go.
Und eine Sache, die mich in Go immer genervt hat.
Stripes, dankeschön für den Sub.
Eine Sache, die mich in Go immer genervt hat, ist, dass Go Interop mit anderen Sprachen so langsam ist.
Die IDE ist absoluter Müll, echt.
Hast du schon ausprobiert?
Wie heißt denn das Ding überhaupt?
Rust Rover.
Was verwendest du, wenn das Kacke ist?
Meistens sind die JetBrains-Dinger doch immer ganz gut.
Aber zumindest Goland ist nice und Ryder ist nice.
Moin.
Was macht Visual Studio Code besser?
Plätzchen, Stelz, Easy Light.
Keine Ahnung, was die da treiben.
Das denke ich persönlich auch.
Es würde mich weniger interessieren, was Mr. Robot nicht gefallen hat.
Beziehungsweise, was ihn wie das Code besser ist.
Update ist raus, installieren wir das Ding.
Das Ding buggt ja vor allem manchmal ein bisschen.
So.
Also, nachdem ich meine Plätzchen weggestelzt habe, kann ich weiter erzählen.
Wie gesagt, ich sage euch gleich, wir machen heute nicht viel WebRTC.
Wenn überhaupt, gar nicht.
Das ist nur, wie ich auf die Idee gekommen bin.
Und zwar, für WebRTC habe ich immer diese Library hier verwendet.
Aber eine Sache, die mich an Go aufrufen aus anderen Sprachen immer extrem abgefuckt hat, ist,
dass das, wenn man das öfters callt, ziemlich langsam ist.
Es gibt zwei Varianten.
Wenn man aus Go selber C-Funktionen aufruft, also quasi von Go andere Sprachen aufruft,
dann ist das langsam, aber es hält sich noch halbwegs in Grenzen.
Wenn man aus anderen Sprachen in Go rein callt, in Go-Code rein callt,
dann ist das in der Vergangenheit zumindest extrem langsam gewesen.
Also, wir reden hier von ein native function call von C-Sharp nach C-Sharp dauert, was weiß ich,
keine Ahnung, eine halbe Nanosekunde oder so.
Es ist kurz.
Und ein call nach Go rein dauert irgendwie 300 Nanosekunden oder so.
Also, Go ist sehr langsam, wenn es um Interop mit anderen Sprachen angeht.
Das hat mich immer genervt, weil ich sende mehrfach, also ich sende 30 mal die Sekunde pro Kamera neue Videoframes nach Go
und die WebRTC-Library verarbeitet die dann.
Heißt, im Endeffekt, ich hab, sag mal, wenn du 30 FPS pro Kamera hast,
hast du 10 Kameras, oder sagst du, du hast 100 Kameras,
dann hast du 3000 Function Calls die Sekunde.
Das ist nicht viel und das ist auch, ganz ehrlich,
selbst wenn es richtig, richtig langsam ist in Go,
nicht so wirklich das Bottleneck, aber mich nervt.
Deswegen wollte ich das erstens mal ausprobieren.
Naja, also es gibt noch nichts zu rewriten in Rust, aber wir probieren das mal in Rust aus.
Also zumindest, wir machen heute kein komplettes WebRTC-Example, vielleicht nächsten Stream oder so,
weil das geht erstmal zum Ausprobieren.
Zumindest wollte ich erstmal ausprobieren, ob das schneller geworden ist mittlerweile.
Also C und Go Interop.
Ich sag C stellvertretend für alle anderen Sprachen, die es gibt,
weil jede Sprache, oder sag mal so, mir fällt keine Sprache ein,
die nicht Interop mit C machen kann.
Wie C Funktionen aufruft, hat sich so ein bisschen als Standard etabliert in der Programmierwelt.
Egal ob das jetzt Python ist, Node, C Sharp, was auch immer,
alle können sie eigentlich dynamisch C Funktionen aufrufen.
Also mir fällt keine Sprache ein, die nicht C Funktionen aufrufen kann.
Sagen wir mal, kompilierte Sachen, die mit C Interface rausgefallen sind.
Und das Ding ist, ich hab irgendwas im Auge, das ist wirklich richtig nervig.
So, und das Ding ist, wir testen jetzt erstmal, ob das schneller geworden ist mit Go.
Was hab ich eigentlich für eine Go-Version drauf hier?
Go-Version, sieht man das?
Ach nee, das ist die Minus-Version, nur so?
Nee, das ist einfach nur Version.
Warum macht das eigentlich jedes Command-Line-Tool irgendwie anders?
Bei Java ist es glaube ich Minus-V oder so.
Das kann man sich ja echt nicht merken.
So, und Rust müssen wir auch gleich mal installieren.
Nee, Rust ist schon installiert.
So, und der Kompilierer für die deutsche Programmiersprache, oje.
Ja, das mit dem einen Minus ist in der Go-Welt voll verbreitet.
Ich verstehe es ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Man hätte sich da ein bisschen an Lilux-Standards halten können.
Und Lilux-Standard ist Minus Minus ausgeschrieben, einfaches Minus mit Abkürzung.
Aber Go hat sich gedacht, scheiß drauf, wir lassen das einfach.
Wobei, in dem Fall ist es ja sogar nicht nur einfaches Minus, sondern sogar ganz ohne Minus, also Sub-Command.
Leute, wartet mal, ich muss mal kurz Wasser ins Auge machen, ey.
I-Champ gefixt, hoffe ich.
Ja, bei Git ist es auch so.
Wobei, bei Git bin ich es gewöhnt.
Gar nicht so schlimm, da muss ich einfach nur dran gewöhnen, dass Sub-Commands sind.
Aber Version finde ich halt doof als Sub-Command, Minus Minus Version ist einfach viel intuitiver.
So, also das ist das erste, was ich ausprobieren will.
Ob Go-Interop mit anderen Sprachen immer noch so langsam ist.
Und dann, ja, dann kam das nächste, wie ich auf Rust gekommen bin.
Ich hab gesehen, dass es eine Rust-Reimplementation von dieser Go-Library gibt in Rust.
Also das Ding ist ziemlich beliebt, 11.900 Sterne und das da 3.500 Sterne.
Also fast so viel wie der Fiat-Champ.
Hat da jemand sein Issue geschlossen, kann das sein?
Guck mal, ich sag doch, keine Fehler, keine Fehler im Fiat-Champ.
Einfach immer, versteht keiner, wie man es verwendet.
So, und dann habe ich gefunden, dass es eine Reimplementierung von dieser WebRTC-Library in Rust gibt.
Und dann habe ich mir überlegt, okay, jetzt wäre es doch mal an der Zeit,
bevor ich irgendwie eine der beiden Libraries benutze,
mal zu gucken, was sich prinzipiell angenehmer aus .NET aufrufen lässt.
Rust oder Go.
Ich persönlich tippe drauf, dass es meilenweit Rust sein wird.
Sowohl easier zu benutzen als auch, also nicht zu schreiben, sondern anzusprechen,
als auch deutlich höhere Performance vom Callen von C-Sharp aus.
Aber so ganz sicher bin ich mir nicht.
Ich gehe aber davon aus, dass Rust meilenweit vorne sein wird.
Das Problem an Rust ist, dass Rust absolut abfuck zu schreiben ist.
Aber der Interop mit C-Sharp sollte schneller sein.
Deswegen probieren wir das jetzt überhaupt gar nicht, Leute.
Ich bin ja schon seit MW1 der Meinung, dass das Kreativität komplett bankrott dort ist.
MW2 war schon nochmal der Aufguss des Remake-Aufgusses.
Und MW3 komplett.
Ich habe heute bei Huskers in den Stream reingeguckt,
habe festgestellt, die haben zwar teilweise Karten dabei,
aber das Gameplay, was ich sehe, ist das gleiche Up-Aim-MW1-Reboot-Gameplay
mit ultrahoher Time-to-Kill, also niedriger, niedriger, nicht hoher, niedriger Time-to-Kill.
Also ich habe mir null davon angeguckt, das interessiert mich nicht und ich werde es mir auch nicht kaufen.
Findest du ernsthaft? Ich finde Rust ist eklig.
Ich meine, sowohl Go als auch Rust sind jetzt nicht gerade die schönsten Sprachen,
aber ich finde Rust extrem umständlich.
Deswegen werden wir das jetzt mal ausprobieren.
So, also, was gibt es hier?
Hey Max, kannst du eventuell berichten, wie es in dem Bankenwesen seine Ausbildung zum Anwendungsinformatiker zu machen?
Weiß ich nicht, ich habe keine Ausbildung gemacht in der Finanzbranche,
weder bei der Bank noch bei der Versicherung.
Ich habe bei einem Internetprovider meine Ausbildung gemacht.
Da hatte ich nicht direkt zumindest was damit zu tun.
Nein, du solltest dich dort bewerben, wo die Stelle möglichst vielversprechend aussieht.
Ich meine, der Laden, dass der dir vielleicht zusagen sollte, ist nicht verkehrt.
Aber bewerb dich ruhig bei einer Bank oder bei einer Versicherung oder sowas.
Finanzbranche ist gut, wenn du deinen Fuß in der Tür hast.
Finanzbranche bezahlt mit Abstand am meisten, wenn man sich das anguckt.
Es gibt so eine Tabelle.
Ich glaube, das erste waren Banken, das zweite waren Versicherungen, das dritte war Pharmaindustrie in Deutschland.
Ich glaube, das vierte Automobilindustrie oder sowas für IT-Kräfte.
Es könnte auch umgedreht gewesen sein.
Es könnte auch zuerst Automobil und dann Pharmaindustrie.
Aber der erste Platz, der zweite Platz war auf jeden Fall Banken und das zweite war Versicherung.
Das heißt, wenn du in der Finanzbranche irgendwie deinen Fuß in die Tür kriegst, ist sinnvoll.
Und meistens sind die auch ein bisschen größer, was oftmals echt von Vorteil für die Ausbildung ist.
Also je nachdem, was für eine kleine Klitsche das hier ist,
da wird halt sehr viel so auf Gutmeinen gemacht.
Ob es dann gut ist, weiß man nicht.
Also bei den großen Läden kommt es halt weniger oft vor, dass keiner Plan hat, wie das bei einer Ausbildung laufen soll.
Dass du keinen Ansprechpartner hast, dass sich keiner um dich kümmert und sowas.
Das hast du bei großen Läden weniger.
Und dann hast du in der Finanzbranche einen Fuß in der Tür, was immer gut ist, weil die bezahlen einfach gut.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn du die Möglichkeit hast, das zu machen, würde ich mir das angucken.
So sieht es aus.
Jetzt habe ich erklärt, was wir machen wollen.
Jetzt probieren wir das Ganze mal aus.
Also wir legen mal ein neues Projekt an.
Also wie gesagt, wir fangen ganz simpel an.
Wir machen ein Go-Projekt, exportieren dort eine Funktion, die nichts macht,
rufen die FonziSharp auf und wir machen ein Rust-Projekt mit einer leeren Funktion
und rufen die FonziSharp aus und dann benchmarken wir das erstmal und gucken, was da schneller ist.
Beim reinen FunctionCall.
Da wissen wir auch schon mal, dass das nicht daran liegt, dass die eine Sprache irgendwas besser kann,
als die andere Sprache in der Implementierung, sondern einfach so der reine Funktionsaufruf.
Mal gucken, wie schnell der ist.
Ich würde erwarten, dass der saumäßig schnell ist.
Vielleicht nicht so schnell wie ein Native-Aufruf, .net zu .net, aber immer noch schnell.
Ich weiß aber aus Erfahrung, dass Go-Interop mit anderen Sprachen echt problematisch war in der Vergangenheit.
Gerade wenn das was ist, was wirklich hunderttausendfach aufgerufen wird.
Große Unternehmen haben Ausbildungsverantwortlichen, da passiert sowas eigentlich selten.
Danke.
Was ist für dich groß?
50 Mann sind nicht groß.
100 und 200 Mann sind auch nicht wirklich groß.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das eine T-Bait-Frage ist oder ernst gemeint.
Egal, ich sage dazu nichts, weil wenn ich damit anfange, dann höre ich halt nicht mehr auf.
Das muss nicht sein.
So, dann legen wir mal los.
Ich lege mal ein neues BenchmarkChamp.
Wir testen jetzt erstmal, wie schnell das Ganze ist.
Und wenn das in Rust wirklich, und das ist ja zu erwarten, so viel schneller ist,
dann werde ich demnächst mal etwas WebRTC in Rust programmieren.
Wobei ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich durchdrehen werde dabei.
Ein gutes hat's, ein gutes hat's.
Das ist quasi eine Rust-Reimplementation von der Go-Library hier.
Das heißt, ich hoffe, wenn man die Go-Library ein bisschen kennt, kommt man hier auch ganz gut klar.
Müssen wir mal schauen.
Das ist ziemlich groß.
Da gibt es doch eigentlich Ausbildungsbeauftragte und Leute, die dann einen Blick drauf machen.
Also es ist selten, dass es so reingeschissen wird bei großen Unternehmen, was Ausbildung angeht.
Das sehe ich eher gehäufter bei den kleinen.
Okay, wir installieren mal eine neue .NET-Version.
Wir haben mal Zeit, weil ich glaube, es gibt eine neue Preview-Version.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja, es gibt 8.0.1, wobei 100 haben die glaube ich immer, RC2.
RC2, 2.3.5.0.2.2.
Sag mal, .NET-Team, wie viele Versionsnummern wollt ihr eigentlich noch haben?
8.0, das lasse ich mir ja noch gefallen.
8.0.100 ist schon ein bisschen pp-iger, aber auch noch okay.
Aber 8.0.100-RC2.2.3.5.0.2.2.
Also irgendwann ist auch mal gut.
Also ich meine, bis hierhin geht es ja irgendwie noch halbwegs klar.
Aber das dahinter ist schon komplett bescheuert.
Das hat dann mit Semware auch nichts mehr zu tun.
Das interessiert Microsoft eh nicht.
Also, .NET-New-Console.
Wir machen mal ein paar neue Ordner.
Wir machen mkdir Rust, mkdir Go, mkdir Benchmark.
Benchmark legen wir das .NET-Projekt an.
Wow, der für Schmerzen.
Blazer, wen interessiert Blazer?
Wer auch immer das benutzt.
Also Microsoft will das zur Zeit boosten wie sonst was.
Aber auch wenn ich ein großer C-Sharp-Fan bin.
Ehrlich, im Browser wie es bisher ist, brauche ich das nicht.
So, dann haben wir hier Go und haben Rust.
Dann kopieren wir uns mal das Verzeichnis.
Und ich würde sagen, dann fangen wir mal ganz easy an.
Öffnen wir das mal in Rider.
Und tun mal so, als wüssten wir was wir machen.
So, Repos, wie habe ich das genannt?
Nicht Backup.
Benchmark, Champ.
Hier, da, öffnen.
So, hier auf dem vierten Bildschirm machen wir Go Land auf.
Und auf dem fünften, auf dem fünften.
Boah, das kostet RAM, Leute.
Das kostet RAM, Alter.
Drei JetBrains Ideen ist offen.
Ihr MonkaS Javer, Alter.
Und hier machen wir das Rust-Ding auf.
I confirm that I have Red X.
Ja, ja, ja, ich konfirme.
Ich konfirme alles hier.
Wir wollen nichts senden.
Rust-Version detected.
173.0
Perfekt, top.
Wir wollen allerdings Location Repos.
Benchmark, Champ.
Rust.
Da wollen wir rein.
Binary Application.
Standard Library.
Egal.
Die Standard Library von dieser Version halt.
Ich weiß nicht, wo die ist.
Rust.
Let's go.
Oh, geht ja gut los.
Erstmal Minischrift.
Und als nächstes irgendwelche komischen Errors.
Nice.
Rust am Start.
Cargo failed.
Sync Rust Project.
Retrieving Rust Standard Lib.
Hä, warum muss er die noch retrieven, bitteschön?
Rust kommt mit der Standard Library dabei.
Deswegen heißt es Standard Library.
Rust up not found.
Ja, und jetzt?
Kann das sein, dass der Rust up braucht?
Damit das hier funktioniert?
Ich kann auch Rust up installieren, wenn es sein muss.
Ja, easy.
Rust up.
Installieren wir Rust up, auch gut.
Deinstallieren wir Rust, installieren wir Rust up.
Top.
Ist jetzt Cargo und so da?
Was?
Run Rust Default Stable.
Okay, nice.
Das mag ich.
Das mag ich an Rust.
Also unabhängig davon, dass die Sprache ein bisschen eklig zu schreiben ist.
Die Command-Line-Tools
und das wie das ausgeliefert ist,
ist wirklich ziemlich gut gemacht.
Das Ziel ist, sowohl Rust
als auch Go aus die Sharp aus aufzurufen
mit C-Interface und zu gucken, was
schneller ist.
Nur in diesem einen Fall.
Also jetzt nicht die Sprache an sich,
da dürfte Rust vorne liegen,
sondern nur das Aufrufen aus der
anderen Programmiersprache aus.
Da dürfte allerdings Rust auch meilenweit vorne liegen,
weil Go ist mega langsam.
Interop mit anderen Sprachen.
Zumindest war das in der Vergangenheit so.
Es wird aufgerufen
C-Sharp nach Go und C-Sharp nach Rust.
Es wird nicht C-Sharp Go Rust aufgerufen.
Es wird C-Sharp nach Go
und dann C-Sharp nach Rust aufgerufen.
Ich tippe einfach, dass Rust
in allen Belangen komplett
meilenweit ahead of Go ist,
weil Go bekannt dafür ist, dass Go langsam ist
als Interop mit anderen Sprachen.
Also langsamer als ziemlich jede andere
technisch bekannte Programmiersprache.
Und Go ist super langsam, was das angeht.
Also das ist langsamer
als so ziemlich jede andere Sprache,
die mir so einfällt.
Das ist langsamer als
Python, also nur in diesem
einen Fall.
Also Callen von und nach
anderen Sprachen über irgendeinen
C-Interface.
Das ist langsamer als Python, als Java,
als alles.
Einfach nur Javascript.
Das ist wirklich,
Go ansonsten ist ja recht flott,
aber in dem Bereich ist es wirklich
pepega langsam.
So, also, hat es jetzt,
jetzt starten wir nochmal dieses Rusting,
ob das jetzt besser funktioniert, nachdem ich
Rustup installiert hab.
Ja nice, scheint zu funktionieren.
Was hat Go für Vorteile?
Go hat
ein paar Vorteile. Zum Beispiel
ist Go relativ flott.
Wie gesagt, was langsam ist,
ist ja nur diese eine Sache, die ich gerade
gesagt habe. Champ, schön vielen Dank für den
Sub. Ansonsten
ist Go relativ flott.
Go ist richtig
gut, wenn man self-contained
binaries haben möchte, die rückwärtskompatibel
einfach auf jedem Linux-System laufen.
Da ist Go so ziemlich die beste Sprache,
die es gibt, die existiert, die man dafür
benutzen kann.
Auch im Cloud-Umfeld
ist Go
sehr beliebt. Warum kann ich die
Preise nicht ändern?
Und? Ach, jetzt geht es
auf einmal, okay.
JetBrains Mono, meinetwegen.
Aber
ich glaube, die Schriftgröße ist ganz okay,
oder? Ich glaube,
Chatgy, ich muss mal kurz
in meiner Vorschau gucken. Ja, die Schriftgröße ist
gut. Ich sehe das gerade hier in der Vorschau,
die ist okay, da kann man nichts sagen.
Das ist eigentlich sehr
angenehm zu lesen gerade. Ich gucke mir das gerade
auf dem Vorschau-Monitor an.
Auch nettes,
recht nicht so ins Auge
brennende Dark-Theme dabei,
das ist okay. So,
Main Print Hello World, ja, das kommt schon mal weg.
Wir brauchen gar keine Main-Funktion.
Ach so, ja, Moment.
Ich muss das ja umstellen auf eine Library.
Wir legen erst mal das Go-Projekt
an. Was haben wir hier noch offen?
New Session, New Message,
Create Session,
New Sender. Ach so, ah,
ich weiß, das ist, ja, ja, ja, das
haben wir mal gebaut. Das können wir wegmachen.
Da müssen wir ein neues
Projekt anlegen.
Also legen wir ein neues Go-Projekt an.
Wo ist das hier? Go,
New, Project.
Und zwar
wollen wir nach Repos
Benchmark
Champ Go. Und jetzt
wollen wir ein Go-Modules
Projekt anlegen. Ich glaube, das macht er
standardmäßig.
Was ist Enable Vendoring Support?
Äh,
verstehe ich nicht.
Sollte ich das an- oder ausschalten?
Ich verstehe die Hilfe
nicht. Kann weg.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es mir überhaupt sagen
soll, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay, ihr habt auch keine Ahnung. Wenn der Chat
keine Ahnung hat, dann beruhigt mich das immer.
Okay, Create,
this Window, Close.
So, jetzt muss ich erst mal gucken, dass ich wieder ein bisschen
anfange, Go zu checken.
Go war doch so.
So, wir gehen jetzt mal Repo,
Benchmark Champ,
Go. Und jetzt
sagen wir
Go Run. Und dann
kackts ab. Weil,
Missing Go Version in Modload.
Nice.
Achso, es fehlt ne Main, oder?
Es fehlt einfach ne Main-Datei.
Dann ist die Fehlermeldung, aber ppga.svg.
Also New Go File
Main.go
Package.
Moment, warum
heißt das Projekt Go? Das ergibt doch
gar keinen Sinn. Das Projekt
soll heißen...
Achso, das heißt so wie der Ordner.
Und das hier heißt auch Rust.
Das ist ja egal. Es sollte durchaus auch okay sein,
dass das heißt. So, Package
Main muss das ja sein.
Weil wir sind ja hier in Go. Und dann brauchen wir
Function
Main. Und dann sagen wir so was wie
fmt.brindln.
kack wait.
So, und das sollte jetzt kompilieren, oder?
Nein. Warum nicht?
Das darf bestimmt nicht so heißen,
oder? Das ist bestimmt ppga.
Weil der Ordner Go heißt. Garantiert
kann das das nicht ab, weil der Ordner Go heißt.
Könnte ich wetten mit euch.
Was? Go mod init?
Das muss man doch normalerweise nie machen.
Äh.
Mod?
Already exists.
Das ist 100 Pro. Ich wette mit euch.
Das ist, weil der Ordner
Go heißt.
Go hat so komische Dinger.
Das kann ich mir richtig gut vorstellen.
Wir löschen das nochmal.
Man zieht ja ins Terminal nicht.
Ja, in dem Fall gibt es da eh nichts.
Wir löschen das nochmal.
Und machen mktl go app. Okay?
So, das sollte
nicht problematisch sein.
Also, new project.
Jetzt hat er das schon wieder.
Jetzt lasse ich das mal enabled.
Vielleicht macht es das dann richtig.
Wir wollen nach benchmark champ
go app
und eigentlich da rein direkt. Genau.
Create.
Und jetzt sage ich
go app
go run Punkt.
Jetzt funktioniert es auch.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das an diesem automatischen
Vendoring Support lag, was auch immer das macht.
Oder weil das Ding...
Ich tippe auf den Ordner Namen.
Bei Go weißt du nie.
Go hat so viele Magic Sachen,
weil sie so sein müssen.
Beispielsweise auch Klammern bei einem if oder so.
Dass ich mir das gut vorstellen kann.
Main Punkt Go.
Das ist auch merkwürdig gemacht,
dass das nicht so heißen darf wie die App.
So, und jetzt machen wir hier
Function main
fmt prindeln
check wait.
Das sollte jetzt funktionieren.
Okay, nice. Funktioniert.
Mal kurz checken, ob Rust auch funktioniert.
Seht ihr das Terminal hier,
wenn ich da was tippe?
Hier unten. Sieht man das?
Da ist der Chat davor, gell?
Dann machen wir es so.
Dann seht ihr es auf jeden Fall.
Jetzt ist genug Platz unter Chico
hier rechts. Da sieht man nichts.
Dann machen wir auch das Terminal
hier unten drunter.
So, ja.
Also Repos, Benchmark,
Champ, Rust.
Und jetzt machen wir mal,
ich glaube Cargo run ist es.
Okay, Rust
kompiliert fehlerfrei.
Erstmal im Kalender anmarken.
Tja,
jetzt geht es schon los.
Ich glaube,
es ist prindeln, ne?
Auch in Rust.
Check wait.
Okay, ja. Funktioniert. Nice.
Okay, also.
Jetzt kommt das nächste.
Also das ist jetzt ja einfach nur,
um zu gucken, ob alles richtig aufgesetzt ist.
So, also.
Was hat er hier für Schmerzen?
Could not load.
Ah, ja.
Das liegt,
nicht toll sein Bild.
Das liegt daran, dass er meine .NET Version
nicht erkannt hat. Warum auch immer.
Reload project.
Jetzt sollte es hoffentlich gleich gehen.
Machen wir auch nochmal
eine Konsole auf.
CD, Repos, Benchmark,
.NET,
Run.
Ja, Funzt. Okay.
Alles klar.
Also, was ich jetzt vorhabe, ist folgendes.
Ich möchte jetzt sowas hier machen.
Ich will jetzt, wir brauchen,
wir machen mal
den .NET Teil.
Als erstes und dann den anderen.
Wir machen jetzt mal eine Datei interop.cs
Die kriegt
eine public,
eine uns,
eine unsafe public
static class.
Warum unsafe?
Naja, weil ich
zähe Sachen mit Pointern und so in anderen Sprachen
aufrufen will. Also das muss unsafe sein.
Und damit das funktioniert,
muss ich unsafe
erlauben.
Ich weiß eh nicht, warum das nicht standardmäßig
an ist. Ich meine, wenn man es nicht verwendet, verwendet man es
halt nicht. So.
Und jetzt
will ich beispielsweise sowas hier
aufrufen.
DLL-Import
von, ja,
RustLib
will ich aufrufen.
Eine Funktion, die
boah, DLL-Import-Syntax
Moment. Muss ich mir abgucken.
Ich glaube, static-extern
oder irgendwie so muss das aussehen.
Public
static-extern, genau.
So, public static-extern.
Das heißt ja hier irgendwie
call me, so.
Einfach nur call heißt das Ding.
Also, was das macht,
was noch nicht geht, weil es ist noch nicht da.
Damit kann ich jetzt aus C-Sharp
eine Funktion aufrufen,
die in Rust, in einer
Library, in einer
Rust-Library, die mit C-Interface
kompiliert wurde, existiert.
Aufrufen.
Void fehlt noch.
Und hiermit
kann ich, achso, die sollte ich vielleicht
ein bisschen anders nennen.
Call me Rust
Call, oder einfach nur
Call Go.
Ich muss nur gucken, dass die Libraries
am Ende dann richtig heißen. Also, das
sucht jetzt nach einer Library, die
RustLib heißt, irgendwo hier im Verzeichnis.
Oder GoLib, die gibt es noch nicht.
Die müssen wir anlegen.
Und dort drin ruft es dann eine
Funktion auf, die heißt Call Go
und Call Rust. Das wird erstmal eine
leere Funktion sein.
Man kann mit C-Sharp DLLs
erstellen, nein, man kann aber
native Funktionen
importieren, beziehungsweise aufrufen, die
in DLLs
oder in unter linux.so
Dateien vorhanden sind.
Also, dynamic
loading. So, und mein
Ziel ist dann sowas zu machen hier.
Interop
Punkt, Call
Call Rust.
Wenn ich das jetzt aufrufe, wird Folgendes passieren.
Bam!
Er findet nämlich GoLib
und
RustLib nicht.
Ist aber auch klar, die haben wir noch nicht angelegt.
Die gibt es schlicht und ergreifend noch gar nicht.
Ich würde sagen, wir fangen mal mit dem
Go-Teil an. Da weiß ich noch
ungefähr, so ganz grob,
wie es aussehen muss,
dass das funktioniert. Und zwar,
wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe,
muss man jetzt Folgendes machen.
Wir legen jetzt mal in Go was an.
Die Main-Funktion brauchen wir nicht.
Weil wir rufen, wir starten
ja kein Binary, sondern wir
callen FonziSharp in was rein,
was in Go definiert ist. Also, das
ist natürlich auch der Einstiegspunkt.
Nicht Main, sondern der Einstiegspunkt in dem Fall ist
Call Go, weil das ist, was wir aufrufen.
So, wenn ich das noch richtig im Kopf habe,
wie das funktioniert in Go, dann sagt man
hier Function, die
muss heißen Call Go, so wie
hier. Also, so wie da.
Und dann muss man, glaube ich,
drüber schreiben
Export
Call Go. Entweder
mit Leerzeichen, ne, ohne Leerzeichen.
Und ich glaube, so muss man
das machen, dass Go
das als C-Interface exportiert.
Aber das war noch
nicht alles.
Go run, ne, das geht natürlich nicht.
Ähm, oh
Shit. Go kompilieren
als C-Library,
beziehungsweise mit C-Interface. Wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Oh,
meine Güte. Ähm, muss ich nachgucken.
C Go Compile.
Ach, Import C musste man
auch noch machen. Ja, ja, okay.
Genau, genau. Gut, dass wir in die
Hilfe gucken. Das musste man auch
noch machen am Anfang. Also,
das braucht man,
das braucht man in Go, damit man
aus Go C-Libraries aufrufen kann.
Und das hier braucht man,
damit man aus anderen Sprachen Go
Sachen aufrufen kann, über
ein C-Interface, was generiert wird.
Ich glaube,
man braucht beides, oder?
Egal, schadet auf jeden Fall nix.
Was auch immer
das da jetzt ist,
keine Ahnung.
Äh, what the...
Ich suche
den Go Build Aufruf dafür.
Go Build, man muss irgendwie
C Go Enable oder sowas machen.
Ich hab das noch
im Hinterkopf irgendwie.
Go Build,
ich weiß aber nur nicht mehr, hab ich das vielleicht
hier irgendwo... Ne.
Hab ich das vielleicht in der anderen
VM noch
als History?
Kann GCC auch Go
kompilieren? Ja,
es gibt ein GCC
Plugin für Go, aber das verwendet glaube ich
meines Wissens nach so gut wie niemand.
C Go?
Gleich?
Ah, shit,
haben wir es auch nicht in der History mal drin.
Wie war das denn
jetzt nochmal?
Hier, C Go Enable, genau.
Ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe auch gar nicht,
wozu das gut sein soll. Ja, C Go Enable,
genau, das suche ich. C Go
Enable. Aber
die Frage ist, wie man es jetzt nochmal aufruft.
Env
Go OS Linux?
C Go Enable.
Okay, das
ging irgendwie so. C...
Es ist auf jeden Fall Env.
C Go
Enable
gleich 1
und dann sagt man glaube ich einfach Go Build?
Ne.
Aber ich bin ja auch falsch hier.
Ich muss ja auch in mein Go Projekt.
Ja, das wird jetzt ein bisschen abartig,
bis das funktioniert.
Im Moment halt einfach funktioniert gerade.
Nein,
das ist falsch.
Der soll das als Library kompilieren.
Äh,
Build Mode, oh meine Güte, wie geht das?
Go Shared
Shared
Library
Shared Libraries in Go,
how to use? Go Shared Libraries
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Building
Shared Libraries in Go.
Genau, wie ging das nochmal?
Ich hab das, das ist ja manchmal
in der History gar nicht so gut.
Weil,
wenn man dann seine History nicht hat,
hier,
Build Mode gleich C Shared
minus O Preload, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was das bedeuten soll. Ich lass das einfach mal weg.
Was?
Okay, was auch immer.
Also wahrscheinlich brauchen wir
jetzt noch das hier dabei.
Ach ne, das muss hier bei
Go Build hin.
Ja, schon besser, schon besser.
Aber wo ist meine Library?
Ach, Go App ist die Library.
Okay, das Ding soll heißen,
ach dem ist ja,
ach, okay, also,
äh,
wenn ich,
Moment, warum ist der Aufruf nicht in meiner History drin?
What the?
Ach so, weil ein Leerzeichen davor war.
Lul.
Ja, na, dann ist klar,
dass das nicht drin steht.
Minus O,
der Output soll sein,
wie hab ich das genannt in .NET?
Golib.
Golib.so
Ja,
sehr schön, genau, genau, genau, genau.
So will ich das haben.
Okay, Golib.so
soll er bauen und dann
soll er das Ganze moven,
Golib.so
moven hoch in das C Sharp
Projekt.
Golib.so, okay, nice.
So, wenn ich Glück hab,
klappt das jetzt schon.
Fuck.
Cannot open.
Ah, ich weiß warum.
Weil ich pp-ger bin.
Ich muss die
Build Action noch umstellen, dass der das
ins Output Directory kopiert.
Und jetzt scrollt's, präge Leute, präge.
Ey,
es funzt, es funzt.
Ich kann euch auch beweisen, dass es funzt.
Guckt mal, wir schreiben jetzt hier was
in Go rein, okay?
fmt, prindeln, lul,
kompilieren das,
und jetzt ruf ich's aus C Sharp
auf,
lul.
Und ihr seht hier nirgends wo in C Sharp ist lul definiert,
oder lul, die Ausgabe, die kommt aus Go.
Also jetzt callt, jetzt callt
C Sharp nach Go rein.
Das ist nice.
Wie mach ich in
Chat, wie mach ich denn in Go
ein Release Build?
Ist das standardmäßig ein Release Build?
Nee, nee, C Go
brauch ich, auf jeden Fall.
Weil ich will gleich noch versuchen,
wie das ist, ob man auch in Struct returnen kann
und sowas.
Ähm, äh, was hab ich grade gesagt?
Was wollt ich grade machen?
Jetzt hab ich grad an was anderes gedacht, lul.
Jetzt weiß ich, was ich grad machen wollt. Ähm,
Chat, was hab ich vor zwei Sekunden gesagt?
Oh, du aller Boomer hier, Mann.
Achso, Release Build, ja.
Achso, Release Build. Go, Build,
Release.
Auto Build.
Achso.
Strip Debug Symbols. Nö, nö, nö, nö.
Ach, okay, es gibt gar kein
Debug und Release Build bei Go. Gibt es nur,
gibt es nur Release Builds, quasi.
Was für eine Linungsliste
ist drüber zugenommen? Das ist Arch, by the way.
Wenn du es genau wissen willst,
dafür hab ich natürlich schon mal mein Neo
Fetch vorbereitet, damit ich euch regelmäßig
sagen kann, dass ich Arch Linungs verwende.
Das ist Arch Linungs, allerdings in der
VM. Und
das Terminal ist West Term.
Das ist die 3 als
Window Manager und ZSH
als Shell.
Wenn's dich
genau interessiert, wie das alles konfiguriert
ist und funktioniert, kannst du auf
GitHub gucken, hier ist meine ganze
Konfig. Und wenn du grad dabei
bist, kann ich dir empfehlen,
schnapp dir auch noch gleich die passenden Desktop
Hintergründe,
dass du auch
White Paper Happy hast,
im Hintergrund, so wie ich.
Was ist One Fetch?
Is One Fetch die coolere Neo
Fetch Variante
oder was?
Command Line Git Information Tool.
Was ist das?
Written in Rust, natürlich!
Die Krustentiere sind wieder am Start.
Ach, da kriegt man
Infos über das Repo angezeigt.
Ja, das ist doch eigentlich auch ganz cool.
So.
Also das Call nach
Go Code funktioniert schon einmal.
So,
wir können jetzt natürlich noch sagen, .NET
Run minus
C Release, dass es auch im Release Mode
läuft, aber funzt.
Gut, also erster Part
ist geschafft.
Jetzt könnt ihr euch aussuchen,
Chat, ob wir als erstes
den Go Part
vollständig bauen, also vollständig
bauen bedeutet zwei Sachen.
Leider nicht aus Go die nächste
Programmiersprache callen, aus C Sharp die nächste
Programmiersprache callen.
Also, was ich
in den Sprachen machen will,
ich will zwei Sachen jeweils in den Sprachen einbauen.
Und zwar, das erste ist,
eine leere Funktion, die wir aufrufen können.
In dem Fall kommt das mit dem 0 wieder raus,
weil ich will nicht 500 mal 0 ausgeben.
Und
das zweite ist eine Funktion, die
nennen wir einfach hier irgendwie Call Go 2
und die soll ein Struct
returnen.
Und da bin ich mal gespannt, wie ich das
mache, ein Struct
von Go zu returnen in C Sharp,
was man dann dort
auch als Struct quasi
deserialisieren kann und benutzen kann.
Das einfachste wäre natürlich alle seine Daten
irgendwie als JSON String zu returnen
und dann parsen, aber das ist ja langweilig.
Wir wollen das ja richtig auf C eben
Memory Bytes
dann
Casten zu irgendeinem Struct.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie das geht, ich hab keinen Plan.
Ne, auch nicht gRPC,
das ist wirklich richtig, richtig Low Level Memory
hin und her schieben soll das sein.
So.
Also ihr könnt euch jetzt aussuchen, wollen wir jetzt den
Go Part noch implementieren, also sprich
die Funktion in Go, die
den Struct zurückliefert an C Sharp
oder wollen wir jetzt erstmal gucken,
wie man Rust
callen kann von C Sharp aus.
Könnt ihr euch aussuchen.
War was? Rust,
erstmal Go fertig.
Go fertig. Go.
Okay.
Also, Tommy,
die meisten Leute wollen Go haben.
Ich denke nicht, dass das so lang
dauert, wobei ich das noch nicht gemacht hab.
Structs returnen
von Go nach C Sharp.
Ich würde sagen, wir fangen mal easy
an, okay? Wir fangen mal easy
an. Easy heißt,
wir returnen hier jetzt ein
Moment.
Wie ging das nochmal?
Ich glaube einfach
sagen wir mal
in den UN64
returnen wir jetzt hier mal.
So. Und jetzt sagen wir hier
return 1.
Mein einfacher geht's nicht mehr, okay?
Return 1, kompiliert auch ohne
Fehler. Und jetzt ist die Frage,
das dürfte ziemlich easy
sein. Jetzt gehe ich hier einfach hin,
ich kommentiere mal das Rusting aus.
Jetzt ist der return-Typ nicht
void, sondern der return-Typ ist UN64.
Das Ding ist nur, ich
hab keine Ahnung, ob die
Repräsentation im Speicher
von einem C Sharp UN und einem
C
aus Go exportierten
C UN die gleiche
ist. Moment, geht das überhaupt so?
Das geht doch
eigentlich gar nicht. Ich will ja kein
Rust UN exportieren,
sondern ein C
UN 64.
Also es könnte sein, dass
das funktioniert, wenn die
Implementierungen einfach überall gleich sind.
Probieren wir das mal
aus, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das
funktioniert. Machen wir mal I.
Ups. Hä?
Da sollte jetzt
1 rauskommen. 1. Okay.
Das funktioniert, aber ich glaube ganz
korrekt ist das nicht.
Das funktioniert wirklich nur,
weil das Memory-Layout von einem
UN 64 einfach in C Sharp
und Go gleich ist.
Ich glaube korrekt wäre
hier gewesen zu returnen ein
C Punkt UN 64
oder sowas.
Gibt es nicht. Ne, wie
heißt das? T oder so, gell?
Heißt das so? Ne, ah man.
UN 64
C. Wie heißt der Kram?
UN
64 T.
Hab ich doch.
Gibt es nicht.
Was muss ich denn da inkluden dafür?
Standard
Int, Moment, was?
std
int.h, okay.
Hey, Funst! Nice!
Stack Overflow Triff and Copy Pasting.
Okay, also einzelne
Ints returnen von Go nach C.
Vor allem nach, von
Go
über C nach C Sharp. Funst?
Jetzt ist die Frage,
wie machen wir das mit einem Struct?
Das wird bestimmt etwas
komplizierter.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen, weil
wir brauchen ja einen
C Struct, kein Go Struct.
Okay,
Go Struct to C
Struct.
Layouts sind in C Sharp
recht easy.
Wenn du dem sagst, dass er
wie heißt das?
Serialisieren soll,
dann ist es das gleiche Layout wie von C.
Dann ist das eigentlich kein Ding.
Hoff ich mal.
Genau, genau, das meine ich.
Damit ist das
meistens nicht so ein großes Problem.
Go Lang Struct
with C Struct in C.
Okay, okay, okay.
Nee, der hat einen
Go Struct
mit C Types drinnen.
Das will ich nicht.
Okay, C Go
Return Struct.
How to return Struct
from C Go?
Ja, genau, das will ich haben.
I have found a solution
in C.
Okay, der definiert ein Struct in C.
Gibt es nicht C Pack Unpack?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Go C Pack?
How to return a C Struct from a Go Function?
Genau das will ich wissen.
Okay, Struct Point.
Ich muss das in C definieren
auf jeden Fall.
To access a Struct Type
directly.
Prefix it with Struct Underscore.
Okay.
C Punkt Struct Underscore.
Oh meine Güte.
Jetzt wird es aber Pepega Style.
Also ich glaube, das wird in Rust
deutlich angenehmer sein.
Als in Go.
Also sprich, wir brauchen jetzt...
Nee, Moment.
So.
Und das muss, soweit ich weiß,
dann auch direkt über Import C stehen.
Sonst mag er nicht.
Die Includes können wir dann hier rein machen.
Massive Pepega.
So, jetzt haben wir einen Struct Point.
Wir wollen allerdings nicht Point Return.
Wir wollen ein Struct...
Okay, machen wir einfach mal sowas hier.
Struct Session
hat eine...
Wir machen mal was, was von später
auch sinnvoll irgendwie...
Das einmal gibt es hier ein
Int.
Oder ein
U
Int. Machen wir es mal so.
Ein U Int 64 T.
Client ID.
Und dann
gibt es... Oh, jetzt wird es interessant.
Jetzt gibt es einen String.
Den nennen wir...
Keine Ahnung. Name. Oder so.
Ja. Client Name.
Jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt, wie ich
einen Struct mit einem
Char Pointer
irgendwie rüberkriege in C Sharp.
Ohne,
wohlgemerkt, ohne
Memory Leaks zu verursachen.
Das wird...
Ohje.
Ich weiß leider mal,
wie ich das über... Okay. Return.
Also wie ging das jetzt? C Punkt
Struct Underscore
und dann Session
Und jetzt durfte ich
das so benennen mit
ähm...
Client Name
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wie ist die Syntax?
X. Ah, die Variable
Variable zuerst. Okay.
Ja. Ja, Tommy.
Also Client ID. So.
Das ist jetzt ein C Char
Array oder so.
Ich hoffe,
dass... Nee.
Nee, nee. Das fand ich schon mal nett.
Ohje.
Wie ist das Syntaktisch denn richtig?
Nee, das ist eigentlich okay so.
Und dann haben wir noch was.
Ich weiß das... Moment. Client ID.
Client ID ist 123.
Und dann haben wir noch Client Name.
Client Name ist dann...
Das wird so definitiv nicht
funktionieren, Leute. Das kann ich euch... Das kann ich euch sagen.
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Okay. Das funktioniert schon mal nett.
Also.
Das ist falsch, weil das ist ja auch
ein U Int.
Also das hier muss ja auch
ein sowas hier sein.
Moment. Meine
Go Skills verlassen mich. Ich glaube, das geht so,
dass das
funktioniert.
Ja. Nee.
Achso.
Moment. Ich return ja gar kein Struct.
Ich will das hier returnen.
Okay. Schon besser.
Schon besser. Hätte ich es auch einfach
so returnen können, ohne dass der rummeckert?
Anscheinend.
So. Also das funktioniert nicht.
Ich muss jetzt einen...
Charakter Array
in Go machen. Okay.
Äh.
C String
C Go Return. Wie funzt das?
Return Strings
C Function in Go legen.
C Punkt
C String.
Was ich mache?
Ich rufe aus C Sharp Go
auf über ein C Interface.
Also machen wir es
irgendwie sowas wie
Let String
C String
Moment. Let. Wir sind...
Achso.
Nee. Go.
Nee. Moment.
Zu viele Programmiersprachen auf einmal.
So, oder?
Okay.
Leute. Es kompiliert.
Client Name ist Omega Lul
Keckel HD
XYZ 123.
Könnte ein geiles Passwort sein. Das ist es aber nicht.
Okay. Jetzt returne
ich ein Struct aus Go.
Heißt im Endeffekt, wenn ich
das hier aufrufe, das sollte noch funktionieren.
Weil das erst... Okay.
Das ist schon mal gut.
123 ist die Client ID, die ich hier gesetzt habe.
Das funzt, weil in meinem Struct
vorne immer noch
die Client ID ist. Jetzt ist die große Preisfrage.
Wie kriege ich hier raus
ein Struct?
Also machen wir mal.
Das nennen wir auch Session.
Public
Uint64
Tja.
Client ID. Wir nennen das mal genauso.
Public
String
Das kann ich mir so nicht
vorstellen, dass das funktioniert.
Und selbst wenn es funktioniert,
passiert Memory Leaks.
Das werden wir jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Mal gucken, ob das
C Sharp Interop
Zeug so schlau ist
und erkennt, dass man ja aus einem
C String
ein C Sharp String machen kann.
Automatisch. Da bin ich mal gespannt.
So und das Ding soll heißen
Client Name. Übrigens, die Namen hier
sind vollkommen egal.
Die Namen sind vollkommen wurscht.
Die müssen nicht die gleichen sein wie hier.
Wichtig ist, die Byte Anzahl.
Also dass das hier
quasi so lang ist
und das hier so lang ist und
dass es dann passt im Endeffekt.
Wie das hier heißt, ist vollkommen egal.
Also das Layout im Speicher muss das gleiche sein.
So und jetzt returnen
wir hiervon kein Uint, sondern
eine Session.
Das funktioniert nicht, weil es nicht public ist.
Okay. Session.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Client ID. Ich hoffe,
das geht noch. Okay, das funzt.
Okay, das funzt.
Was ist hier? Warum kann ich
kein Konsole
PPGA IDE gerade
Client Name.
Funzt einfach. Es funktioniert einfach.
Moment.
Der erkennt automatisch.
Der weiß automatisch, wie man
einen C String in einen C Sharp String
Aber das hat 100
pro Memory Leaks. Das hat
sowas von Memory Leaks, Leute. Ich sag's euch.
100 pro hat es
Memory Leaks. Moment. Moment.
Watch 3 minus
H. Wir machen jetzt die simpelste
Variante Memory Leaks zu erkennen.
Passt mal auf. Wir machen jetzt folgendes.
Wir gucken jetzt
mal, ob es Memory Leaks hat.
While true.
While lulw.
Okay. So.
Wir gucken, ob es Memory
Leaks hat. Wir rufen es einfach in der Schleife
auf und gucken, ob
Free runtergeht.
Run. Oh, shit.
Ich glaube, es hat
Naja, nö.
Oder doch. Doch.
Ah. Das ist jetzt
aktuell so gar nicht mal zu
Das ist jetzt, das ist echt schwer.
Der GC
kann es nicht freen, weil der GC
wahrscheinlich kein free...
Nee, nee. Das hat Memory Leaks.
Oder? Oder nicht?
Das hat 100 pro Memory.
Also, wenn das kein Memory Leak hat, dann wundert
es mich extrem. Warum
verursacht das nicht mehr CPU Last?
Nee, macht es doch. Ja.
Memory.
Wir könnten doch einfach mal mit einem Debugger starten.
Schwer zu sagen.
Also, das könnte auch einfach
kein Memory Leak. Aber das wundert
mich. Woher will es
sie scharf festen, wie man das
Ei gibt?
Moment. Moment.
Moment. Moment. Moment. Moment. Hab ich das überhaupt
schon kompiliert jetzt und dahin geschoben?
Wie kann das sein, dass das kein
Memory Leak gibt?
Warum das .NET nicht freeen können soll?
Weil .NET nicht zuständig ist dafür, das zu
freen.
Woher möchte .NET wissen
an der Stelle, dass ich den eigentlichen
Pointer, auf dem das basiert, das im Ursprungsprogramm
nicht mehr verwende?
Wenn ich das selbst
aufrufen würde, dann ist okay.
Aber, dass das
Automatisch Fried wird er gibt Eigentlich Keinen sinn Aber anscheinend
anscheinend funktioniert das
Zappt!Con Danke Für. Den Stab also das ist das
Irgendwas Falsch
Interop Call
Wir MüsSen Mal Kurz was Checken steht Da üBerhaupt was Drinne
Session
Name steht Da üBerhaupt was sinnvolles Drinne Jetzt Ja
Ich bin leute ich bin hochgradig verwirrt dass das kein
Kann das Sein dass es Einfach raus optimiert wird ich bin ich bin echt jetzt begeistert
verwirrt und begeistert gleichzeitig dass es wohl anscheinend Kein
Memory leak
Ergibt
Wir Können das hier nicht mit dem debugger starten und sehen an die ram auslastung also in Visual Studio gibt es
In Visual Studio gibt es ein debugger mit ram auslastung ich weiß nicht wie das hier in
den rider aussieht
Was was Genau MöcHte rider von mir wo ist das wo ist das problem ach hier
rider was willst du von mir
Was hat er Für. Schmerzen mit war der weißt du wo mein dotnet zeug liegt
Also ich würde gerne das kann man
das muss doch hier irgendwie funktionieren benchmark
Wo ist das hier ja richtig runtime korrekt
exec pass korrekt
der
Ja Aber das hier ist doch dort nicht acht stimmt eigentlich
Ja Ja der ruft das nicht der ruft das nicht mit mit dem richtigen mit dem richtigen
mit der richtigen installation auf was aber äußerst pepega ist weil
Hier checkt das hier checkt das ja
Da ist IrGendwas Falsch Falsch
Der benutzt meines ist meine meine system runtime was aber keinen sinn ergibt weil ich überall hier
Überall hier das richtige eingestellt ist auch hier acht guck ich glaube irgendwie das packt rum
Okay, wir probieren jetzt mal was anderes nur um sicherzustellen dass das irgendwie an mir liegt
und zwar
Guck mal was wir jetzt machen wir sind jetzt einfach mal das hier ist jetzt einfach kein string sondern in pointer
Und spätestens jetzt sollte er es ja nicht aufräumen
So mal gucken ob es jetzt memory leaks gibt also ich würde sagen es gibt memory leaks
Ja, ja ja
guck das geht
das geht steil
Ja, also im pointer gibt es memory leaks
Aber wenn es ein string ist dann gibt das woher weiß der dass er das automatisch freigeben kann das ergibt für mich eigentlich überhaupt
Nee guck im string checkt er das ich habe keine ahnung wie warum die runtime so 6 header ist
Aber wenn man ihm sagt ist ein string dann freeter das automatisch
Ich bin begeistert ich hätte nicht damit gerechnet dass das dort netto das dort netto schlauer ist und das kapiert
Macht er da unter der haube irgendwie einen free drauf
Aber woher weiß er überhaupt dass ein free drauf machen darf also das finde ich äußerst
Spannend dass das funktioniert
Der checkt das hätte ich nicht gedacht ich hätte gedacht ich muss das von hand machen also das ist das ist schlau
Also dass das ist von der runtime wirklich schlau dass der den den string ja automatisch freien kann
Das das ding ist nur das ding ist nur
dass eigentlich er das eher nicht machen sollte weil
Er hat keine ahnung ob ich das hier noch irgendwie verwende zum beispiel
Machen wir doch mal was machen wir mal folgendes
Machen wir mal hier das muss man jetzt mit wahr machen glaube ich
Irgendwie so wahr
Und der wird jetzt gefreed
Wobei ne dann ist er wahrscheinlich so schlau
Gute frage
Entdeckt entdeckt
Exposed
Ja die runtime ist so schlau und ruft wirklich free unter der haube
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht aber da sieht man auch schon das kann echt zu problemen führen wenn ich den string noch weiterverwende in dem
Drunter liegenden go programm ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob das ein sinnvolles default verhalten ist dass das immer automatisch einen pointer freed
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher
Aber ich glaube das ist ein sinnvolles default verhalten
Ich glaube das ist ein sinnvolles default verhalten
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher
Wie hast du das rausgefunden?
Indem ich das einfach einmal global angelegt habe
den string und immer den gleichen returne
Und jetzt versucht ihr ihn zum zweiten mal zu freeen
Und das geht natürlich nicht
Also ihr habt . net versucht
Also ich mein ok
In gewisser logik hat das
. net erkennt wir bekommen einen charakter pointer
Und am Ende
Erkennt wir wir bekommen einen character pointer
Erkennt wir wir bekommen einen charakter pointer
Charakterpointer und am wandelnden Charakterpointer um, kopieren quasi den Inhalt in einen .NET-String und dann fremen wir den ursprünglichen Pointer.
Das ist aber eigentlich gar nicht so ungefährlich, weil
.NET, weil es das automatisch macht, weiß doch überhaupt nicht, ob ich den darunter liegenden Characters,
Charakter
Pointer noch weiter verwende, hier beispielsweise.
Also, weiß nicht.
Da bin ich, da gehe ich nicht so d'accord mit,
was das da macht, aber
soll mir recht sein,
in dem Fall funzt einfach ohne mein Zutun.
Ja, wenn man es nicht direkt als String macht, geht das, kann man garantiert unterbinden.
Wir haben es ja gesehen, man kann es schon unterbinden, indem ich hier einfach einen In-Pointer draus mache.
Sobald ich hier einen In-Pointer draus mache, dann, dann wird Memory geleaked as fuck, guck.
Ja,
700 MB,
160 MB, 1,2 Gig, 1,4 Gig, 1,7 Gig.
Also da, also eigentlich hätte ich damit gerechnet, dass ich das eh so machen muss. Charakter-Pointer,
selbst deserialisieren und dann fremen. Also eigentlich dachte ich, ich muss sowas hier machen, sinngemäß.
Session,
In-Pointer, das ist ja im Prinzip nur ein Pointer an die Stelle, wo das Charakter-Array steht,
sondern ich dachte mir, ich muss, ich muss da jetzt sowas hier machen, zum Beispiel.
Ähm,
UTF-8, hier Pointer to String, UTF-8, Client Name. So, wenn ich das mache, sollte es auch Memory Leaks geben, hä?
Das machen soll es auch Memory Leaks.
Achso, Semi-Kolon.
Das sollte auch Memory Leaks geben. Ja, ja, ja, ja, fette, fette Memory Leaks.
250 MB Memory Leaks pro Sekunde.
Ja, so und jetzt dachte ich eigentlich, ich, ich
kopiere mir das hier im .NET String und danach, danach sage ich
Native Memory Free.
Das ist, das ist was Neues, das gibt es noch nicht so lange in C-Sharp, das ist, um
die, den, die Standard, ja, C-Free-Funktion aufzurufen, in der Hoffnung, dass der Code, von dem ich den Pointer bekomme, das mit der Standard C-Free
Geschichte, mit der Standard, Standard C Alloc-Geschichte allockiert hat, den Speicher. Also
hoffen wir einfach mal und jetzt sagen wir hier Session Client Name und jetzt sollte ich,
warum nicht?
Ach, Unsave, ja, ja. Geht nicht, weil
muss ein Void Pointer sein.
Okay, so und jetzt sollte ich auch keine Memory Leaks mehr haben,
weil jetzt mache ich das von Hand. Ich schnappe mir den Pointer, kopiere den in .NET String und
dann free ich den Pointer. So müsste das eigentlich sein.
Und siehe da, es gibt auch keine Memory Leaks mehr.
Also das macht anscheinend, ernsthaft .NET unter der Haube. Das finde ich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
merkwürdig,
dass es das macht.
Sehr komisch, sehr, sehr komisch auf jeden Fall, dass das macht. Wir probieren noch mal was, wir machen jetzt hier noch mal einen String
draus und dann machen wir das, was der Chat sagt, das interessiert mich nämlich echt.
S
Unmanaged
Unmanaged Type, nicht Bool.
Char, ne Moment, was gibt es denn da überhaupt?
Str
Was haben wir? Oh, das ist Windows Shit.
LP String, a single byte, null terminated on the character single. Dann haben wir
LPT String, Unicode Character String.
LPW String, zwei Byte, alles klar.
B String, B-Wall-T String. Alter, Microsoft, es ist ja gut, man, übertreibt es halt nicht.
LPUTF8 String, a pointer to UTF8, Unicode String. Okay, das klingt, das klingt schon mal ganz gut.
Way too dank.
Auch keine Memory Leaks. Okay, okay, das muss man wissen.
Das muss man echt wissen, dass
es ein automatisches Free macht. Ich weiß nicht, nach was ich suchen muss.
Das ist Interessantes, also
Damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet.
Guck, kein Memory Leak.
Das muss man in dem Fall wirklich wissen, weil damit rechnet man eigentlich nicht. Gut, also hätten wir den Part, ich muss sagen, das ging
einfacher als gedacht.
Jetzt benchmarken wir das Ganze mal, so auf die Schnelle.
Wir können danach noch ein ordentliches Benchmark.net Projekt drumherum machen, um es beides zu vergleichen, aber
probieren wir das mal aus.
Übrigens, das da
ist auch PPGA, das hier soll eigentlich die Funktion sein, die nichts returnt und
GoCall2 soll die Funktion sein, die was returnt, sonst wird das nix.
Jetzt müssen wir das hier anlegen, interop.
Ja, kopieren wir das mal, GoCall2 und GoCall2 ist einfach nur Void.
Okay, jetzt benchmarken wir das Ganze mal ganz kurz, auf die Schnelle, also
Stopwatch
Start.
Okay, aus irgendwelchen Gründen funzt mein
Console-Rightline-Makro nicht.
Elapsed
Total
Seconds
Stopwatch Stop und hier dazwischen rufen wir mal auf interop.
So, das hier sollte so gering sein, ein einfacher Function Call, dass das gar nicht auffällt im Endeffekt, ja.
Das ist jetzt, weil er zum ersten Mal aufgerufen wird, da wird ja nix drauf geben, wir machen da mal eine Schleife drum.
So, machen wir mal
100 Aufrufe davon und gucken, wie schnell das ist.
Und einmal rufen wir es vor der Stopwatch auf, damit es nicht mitgezählt wird.
Wo bist du überrascht, dass es Pointer gibt?
Okay, ja, das ist sehr schnell jetzt.
Gibt es in C-Sharp auch einen Typ für String-Pointer?
In C-Sharp sind Strings immer Pointer. String ist ein Ref-Type.
In C-Sharp ist ein String unter der Haube immer ein Pointer.
Ohne, dass du explizit was hinschreibst. In C-Sharp ist eigentlich 90 Prozent der Sachen, die du verwendest, Pointer.
Ohne Pointer-Syntax.
Ich glaube, er meint aber über der, was, wie jetzt?
Ach so, nee, das ist jetzt in dem Falle von Interop mit wirklich Raw-C-Pointern zu Managed-String-Objekten.
Damit geht er echt nicht so um, wie erwartet.
Ja, als dumm gibt es das nur, wenn ich es anscheinend nicht explizit sage. Also,
was ich vermute, was hier passiert, sobald ich hier hinschreibe,
sobald ich hier hinschreibe String,
dann checkt er, wenn das ein
oder, dann erwartet er einen Character-Pointer,
kopiert sich den bis zu einem Null-Terminator in einen .NET-String und macht dann einen Free auf den ursprünglichen Pointer.
Das ist Ultra-Magic unter der Haube, was da passiert.
Und wenn du das nicht haben willst, dann musst du einfach sagen, mach keinen String draus,
sondern nimm den, nimm den Raw-Pointer und dann kannst du ihn selbst auslesen und freen.
Das, das muss ich echt sagen, das ist richtig krasse Magic unter der Haube.
Also, ja, wenn du das in dumm haben willst,
okay, dann was du machen kannst ist, ach, das war, meinst du, du kannst auch sowas machen, ja, das funktioniert auch.
Muss sagen, Unsave-Character-Pointer. Das funktioniert auch, das ist dann, Moment, Moment, das, ha ha,
Debated, nein, das ist nicht das Gleiche. Du musst einen Byte-Pointer,
Pointer auf Start von einem Byte-Array setzen, weil, weil,
das ist auch ein bisschen
eine Verarschung, da müssten wir aufpassen, wenn man einen Character-Pointer macht, in C-Sharp ist das nicht das Gleiche wie ein Character-Pointer in C.
Character und ein Byte ist in C das Gleiche. In C-Sharp ist ein Character zwei Byte, weil C-Sharp-Strings intern als UTF-16 speichert.
Deswegen ist quasi in C,
in C ist das da
quasi mehr oder weniger das Gleiche wie das da und das da auch in C-Sharp, aber in C-Sharp ist
Character-Pointer was anderes. Also das könntest du auch machen, das geht allerdings nur mit Unsave davor, weil sobald du Pointer-Matching machst,
sagt C-Sharp, ah ja, das ist aber, könnt auch in die Hose gehen.
Aber muss man in dem Fall gar nicht, weil tatsächlich die Managed-Implementierung von diesem,
unter der, also unter der Haube machen, machen die schon das Richtige in dem, in dem einen Fall, ja.
Umwandeln, kopieren einen .NET-String und da unten drunter Free-Callen, das ist schon sehr Magic-mäßig.
Nee, nee, das ist egal, unter der Haube ist das alles das Gleiche.
Die, die Interpretation der Daten ist da ein bisschen anders, zum Beispiel, dass du bei einem
Byte
kein Minus drin stehen haben kannst, aber bei einem S-Byte, bei einem Signed-Byte, könntest du theoretisch minus 180, aber das reine
Interpretierungs-, reine Interpretationsfrage, es ist alles in C ein Byte.
Egal, ob es ein Charakter, ein Byte oder, nee, ein Short ist 16, glaube ich, oder? Ist ein Short nicht in C
nicht 2-Byte? Also 1 bis 16.000 noch etwas?
Da bin ich mir jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht sicher. So, aber jetzt haben wir uns,
jetzt haben wir uns etwas sidetracken lassen.
Anscheinend ist .NET mittlerweile so
Five-Head-schlau, dass es, wenn man so komische Dinger macht, wie ich, von denen ich nicht geahnt hätte, dass sie funktionieren,
tatsächlich funktioniert
ohne Memory-Leaks zu verursachen. Das hätte ich wirklich nicht gedacht.
Okay, jetzt wollte ich das mal ganz kurz benchmarken. Wie schnell ist denn das Ganze?
Okay, ein paar Nanosekunden, aber 100 ist ja auch nix.
Machen wir mal 1000
und dann machen wir mal eine Million. Es gibt übrigens ein nices Feature schon seit ein paar C-Sharp-Versionen. Kennt ihr das hier?
Dass man
Underscores in die Zahlen machen kann, die eigentlich nix ändern da dran,
aber viel viel besser lesbar sind. Jetzt erkennt jeder, dass das hier,
das ist eine Million, also dass das quasi zehn Millionen sind. Machen wir das mal weg. Dass das eine Million ist.
Das kann man viel besser, viel besser lesen. Man darf übrigens nicht auf die Idee kommen, so zu versuchen,
weil dann ist das ein Float beziehungsweise ein Double und also mit zwei Punkten geht es dann auch gar nicht.
Aber das hier, aber das hier ist nice. Ja, das andere sind zehn Millionen gewesen.
Es ist kein Unterschied. Also, ob ich so schreibe oder so, unter der Haube kommt genau das Gleiche raus, aber es ist besser lesbar.
Man kann es auch so schreiben, das ist ein bisschen pp-iger, aber es würde auch funktionieren. Oder so, oder so, aber das macht eigentlich keiner.
Also, das finde ich ganz nice, dass einfach Anderscores in Zahlen ignoriert werden. So eine Million Aufrufe.
Oh, das ist schon recht langsam.
90 Millisekunden für eine Million Function Aufrufe.
Ist das ein Callback Function zu einer Go-Funktion?
Das ist kein Callback, das ist ein direkter Call von einer Funktion in Go und zwar der hier.
Guck.
Wir haben eine leere Funktion in Go, die einfach nur Call Go heißt,
die in eine Library reinkompiliert wird. Die Library wird in .NET geladen,
definiert, dass es darin eine Funktion Call Go gibt und dann wird die aufgerufen.
Unter welchen Umständen merkt man das? Naja, ganz ehrlich, eine Million Function Calls sind schon ganz schön viel.
Das wird man normalerweise
nicht wirklich merken. Es sei denn, es sei denn, man hat wirklich irgendwie so eine
irgendein Parser oder so oder irgendwas, wo das millionenfach aufgerufen wird pro Durchgang, dann macht es schon
performantechnisch einiges aus. Ich zeige euch jetzt mal den Unterschied. Wir machen jetzt mal eine
eine Static Public, nennen wir es mal Call
.NET, nennen wir das jetzt mal, okay.
Static Public Void. Also, das ist jetzt eine .NET Funktion.
Nichts irgendwie über Libraries, eine ganz normale .NET Funktion ist das. Und wenn ich die jetzt mal aufrufe hier,
Call .NET, dann werden wir sehen, Bäm, 1,2 Millisekunden.
Und mit Release-Modus wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein bisschen weniger, ja.
Also 500, 500 Nanosekunden
Versus, versus
500 Nanosekunden versus
80 Millisekunden.
Okay, also
C-Interop ist immer noch nicht das Allerschnellste, was man machen kann. Das ist, das ist echt lahm. Das ist wirklich lahm.
80 Millisekunden für eine Million Funktionsaufrufe. Also von .NET nach .NET braucht das Ganze, braucht das Ganze
500 Nanosekunden. Also hier 0,5 Millisekunden und
von .NET nach Go braucht es 80 Millisekunden. In normalen Anwendungen, wo das nicht oft aufgerufen wird, ist es überhaupt gar kein Problem, ja.
Aber so ist schon ordentlich Overhead.
Ich meine, selbst bei meiner WebRTC-Anwendung, wenn man 30 FPS hat pro Kamera und 100 Kameras drin, dann sind das
3000,
3000 Function Calls pro
Sekunde. Das ist halt nix im Endeffekt, nix.
Das ist egal, ob ich Function, ob ich hier C-Go Overhead habe, das juckt einfach nicht.
Für jeden Function Call einen neuen Thread starten,
ist vielleicht ein bisschen Overkill, aber das würde,
würde, würde zumindest teilweise die ganze Sache schneller machen, ja.
Also besser parallel, aber also es ist schon,
ja,
schon ein bisschen, schon ein bisschen langsamer.
Ich glaube, in dem Fall macht .NET gar nicht so viel Magie, sondern es ist eher Go, was die Magie macht. .NET macht in dem Fall ein relativ straight
Call, wie man halt eine C-Funktion callt.
Bisschen Magic bestimmt, aber Go macht halt extrem viel Magic für ihren Threads und, und Runtime-Scheduler,
dass sich das nicht in die Quere kommt. Also C-Go ist
berüchtigt, oder Go ist berüchtigt dafür, dass der Interop mit anderen Sprachen echt langsam ist.
Du hast recht, du hast recht, wer auch immer das gesagt hat, du hast recht, deswegen, deswegen machen wir das jetzt mal im Debug-Modus, du hast recht,
du hast recht. Also im Debug-Modus brauchen wir ungefähr
82 Millisekunden, 85 Millisekunden Go und Call-NET
brauchen wir
eine Millisekunde, okay.
Ja, du hast recht, das könnte durchaus sein, dass sie scharp schlau genug ist und die Funktion rausschmeißt im Release-Modus, weil es feststellt, okay,
das ist eine, das ist eine Schleife mit nichts drinnen, also scheiß drauf, mach weg. Ja.
Test mit einem Print. Print ist immer ganz schlecht für sowas.
Print ist immer ganz, ganz mies.
Print ist auf die Konsole und Single Output und so. Nee, der überspringt, ich hab's jetzt im Debug-Modus, da wird nix, da wird nix geskippt.
Da wird nix geskippt.
Der ruft die wirklich auf.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das ist auch zu erwarten,
dass ein Function Call von .NET nach .NET nahezu kein Overhead hat. Wäre ja auch, wäre ja auch schlimm, wenn nicht.
Okay, also, dann haben wir das jetzt ausprobiert für Go.
Wollen wir mal gucken, wie schnell das mit dem Struct ist.
Oh, das ist natürlich noch mal eine ganze Ecke langsamer.
Hoho.
Ja, es schwankt ein bisschen.
Wir machen gleich mal eine, wir machen gleich mal einen Benchmark. Komm, wir machen jetzt schon einen Benchmark draus.
Wir machen jetzt schon einen Benchmark draus, bevor wir die Rust-Sache basteln.
Nougat.
Benchmark.net
Bam. Mir gefällt C-Sharp auch enorm gut und ich bin wirklich kein Microsoft-Fan.
Ich weiß, ich weiß. Wobei das, das ein uralter Artikel ist, das meinte ich ja, und das ist auch das, was ich am Anfang des Streams gesagt habe.
Dass ich auch mal heute gucken will, wie sehr sich das, wie sehr sich das verbesserte, wie, wie sehr sich das
verbessert hat. C, Go, Interop. Ich denke schon, dass es schneller geworden ist. Wir machen mal kurz eine Benchmark-Klasse.
Public Class, Bench,
Benchmark.
Wie geht, Moment, Moment, wie ging das jetzt noch mal, Moment, Moment, irgendwie Benchmark, Runner, nee, nee, nee, Bench, Benchmark, Runner?
Runner? Benchmark, Runner?
Run, Benchmark, okay.
Das hier oben kommt weg, das,
ein Aufruf hier oben ist okay, das kommt da rein.
Public, Void, das nennen wir jetzt einfach mal irgendwie Run,
Run, Go oder so.
Dann kommt das hier rein. Machen wir, machen wir aber mal nur, nur,
ja doch, na komm, 1000, 1000 Aufrufe ist vielleicht besser, da kann das mehrfach, mehrfach die Funktion aufrufen.
Okay, Go, Run.
Und jetzt,
ich glaube, jetzt muss man hier noch Benchmark drüber schreiben, ne?
Okay, so und jetzt sollte er eine ordentliche Ausgabe haben, wie schnell der ist.
Zack.
Wow, wat?
There are not any result runs, warum?
Failed. Der erkennt wieder mein .NET nicht. Mann, was ist das für ein Upfuck? Okay, Export, hier, Path,
Export, .NET, kann man hier drinnen, kann man hier drinnen relative Farbe verwenden?
Gar nicht sicher. .NET,
Version,
Minus, Minus, Version, 7, nee.
Also, Home,
Max,
Jetzt ist es 8, okay.
Mach doch in die Bash-RC. Eigentlich will ich meine System.NET Version nicht überschreiben.
So.
Und jetzt sagen wir Run, Release, jetzt soll es hoffentlich gehen.
Jetzt wird ordentlich gebenchmarkt, fast wie in einem Nick Chapsas Video hier. Der Benchmarkt auch immer.
50 Mal.
Falls dir jemand guckt.
Da wird auch immer bis zum Umkippen gebenchmarkt.
Wenn du Variable für die Anzahl machst, kannst du die Anzahl der Durchläufe testen.
So, also, Go hat im Durchschnitt
Mikrosekunden.
Also für
1000 Aufrufe.
Das ist jetzt halt nicht, nicht so schnell.
Warum? Warum?
Ich brauche ja keine Parameter, oder?
Hast du dir mal das Video angeguckt? Da muss ich nicht das Video angucken, das habe ich oft genug erzählt, dass die .NET Versionierung
beschissen ist. Da habe ich ja schon, da habe ich ja schon selbst oft genug gesagt, also, ach komm.
Machen wir einfach, machen wir nur 100.
Und wir callen jetzt das ohne Overhead, also das, was nix macht.
So, und jetzt das Ganze noch einmal für Rust. Auf geht's.
Krustentiere versammeln. Ah ja, ja, danke schön für den Sub.
Bolgi19.
Huge Subscription.
Sorry, falls ich irgendjemanden übersehen habe, ich gucke mal kurz rein.
Creator Dashboard.
Der Karlzon, danke für den Sub, haben wir hier den ZeppCon.
Shapeshifter und Stripes. Der Razer hat auch Subscribed vorhin noch, der Alfred auch.
Gar nicht richtig gesehen, alles hier.
Vomax heute morgen.
So, also, es wird Zeit für Go.
Wir kommentieren das hier gerade mal aus.
Und ich sage jetzt mal,
Call.
Wir brauchen jetzt, wir brauchen jetzt Call
Call Rust.
Das wird nicht funktionieren, weil es das auch nicht gibt.
Ja, bam, Crash, gibt es nicht. So, also, ich muss jetzt in Rust eine Library erzeugen, die RustLib heißt.
Jetzt geht es los. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wirklich absolut keinen blassen Schimmer, wie ich das jetzt machen soll.
Okay, also, müssen wir mal suchen. Rust
FFI
The Rustonomicon. Okay, jetzt kriegen wir es erklärt.
Also, Calling Foreign Functions.
Rust ist so eklig. Alter, wenn ich das hier schon sehe. Ich dreh aber.
Create Type.
Wie macht man das überhaupt? Da gab es doch mal irgendein GitHub.
Rust FFI Examples.
Gucken wir mal.
Hat er denn? C Sharp to Rust, das ist doch schon mal ein gutes Beispiel.
Ja, Cargo Tommel.
Also, das braucht man. Lib.
Okay, also, let's go. Wir müssen in unsere Cargo Tommel gehen.
Und da jetzt ein Lib hinzufügen. Lib.
Name ist einfach
RustLib. RustLib, so wahrscheinlich, wie der Output heißen soll.
CD Lib klingt gut.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie funzt das? Source, Lib S.
Ja, copy-pasten wir uns mal hier rein und nennen es Call Rust, aber wir haben kein Input und wir haben kein Output erst mal.
No Mängel extern FN Call Rust.
Das hier bedeutet, glaube ich, dass er die Namen genauso lässt, wie die Funktion heißt, sodass sie später aufgerufen werden kann.
Und Main können wir eigentlich raus machen. No Main Function Found. Ja, ist doch klar, will ich auch nicht mehr.
Cannot Find Library RustLib. Rename File zu...
Okay. Source Main in Lib. S.
Achso, Cargo Run geht natürlich. Cargo Build. Ohne Fehler hat es gebildet. Ich fass es nicht.
Und jetzt, wo ist das Ganze? Target. Debug.
Lib. Lib. Rust. Lib.
Hört sich ein bisschen kacke vielleicht an, oder?
Wie habe ich es genannt? Ich habe es einfach nur RustLib genannt. Also, dann heißt es hier einfach nur Rust.
Build.
Lib Rust Punkt S. Ja, meinetwegen, dann heißt es halt nicht RustLib, sondern Lib Rust.
Auch gut, kann ich auch mit leben, okay?
Und jetzt Build. Okay, Minus Minus Release.
Wobei eigentlich wurscht es, wie ich das nenne. Wir können auch sagen Build Release. Dann sagen wir CP oder MV.
Target. Build. Release. Lib Rust Punkt S. O. Hoch zu...
Benchmark.
Und dann soll das einfach heißen
RustLib Punkt S. O. Ich benenne es einfach um.
Doch, doch. Das ist eigentlich schon richtig. Ich habe es nur falschrum benannt. Ich habe es falschrum benannt. Lib, das ist auf jeden Fall
so, so ist richtiger als meins. Mit Lib zuerst.
Okay, so jetzt haben wir in unserem .NET Projekt noch eine RustLib. Die fügen wir hinzu in den Output.
Dass er die auch findet, wenn er dann später, später läuft. Ja, so, also Build Action.
Copy hier. Zack. So, und wenn wir Glück haben, funktioniert das jetzt schon.
Hey, es läuft. Rust Aufruf. Funzt. So, Beweis. Moment. Beweis, dass es funktioniert.
Source.
Print.
Was ist das? Module. Declaration. Reload. Immer. Restart. Hilft immer.
Okay, nice. So, jetzt bin ich mal hier. Das Brindeln.
Cack W.
Build. Und jetzt aufrufen von .NET aus. Moment. Oh, zu viele Fenster. Aufrufen von .NET auf. Cack W.
Funzt. Sehr gut.
Exzellent. Okay, jetzt können wir mal testen, wie schnell das ist, in Go das, in Rust das Ganze zu machen.
Und danach bauen wir das noch mit Rust und Struct zurückgeben.
Also, wir sagen jetzt Interop. Call. Go.
Und zwar mein Benchmark.
Interop. Call. Net. Wir machen jetzt alle drei Sachen.
So, also wir kopieren uns den Benchmark.
Und den Benchmark. Sagen wir Run. Go. Run. Rust. Und Run. .NET. Das sollte ja eigentlich das Schnellste sein.
Call. Net.
Und hier Rust. Jetzt bin ich mal auf die Ergebnisse gespannt, was da rauskommt.
C. Release. Wir machen es auch so schnell, wie geht. Zack.
Lassen wir das mal kurz laufen und ich gucke in den Chat. Moin, bin aktuell auf Windows. Man würde gerne auf Linux rüber wechseln.
OS gefällt mir sehr. Jedoch zweifle ich noch, da ich gerne zocke und ich weiß, wie gut das unter Linux funktioniert. Ganz ehrlich,
wenn du viel spielst und je nachdem, was du spielst, wenn du Spiele beispielsweise mit Anti-Cheat spielst, also
wobei CS ja wohl mittlerweile ganz gut funktioniert, aber wenn du sowas wie, sagen wir mal,
Rainbow Six, Fortnite oder sowas spielst, dann hast du eigentlich verloren unter Linux.
Ich würde dir empfehlen, mach das so wie ich erstmal. Benutz Windows als Host
und auf dem zweiten Windows-Desktop eine Linux-VM mit Fullscreen, wo du zwischendrin hin- und herschalten kannst. Du machst in der Linux-VM alles, was du
machen willst, was gut unter Linux ist und für Sachen wie
Videos gucken,
streamen, Videobearbeitung,
irgendwelche
Games, dann machst du es unter Windows. Da hast du, finde ich, das Beste aus beiden Welten und das Gute ist,
du kannst dich ein bisschen an Linux gewöhnen, ohne dass du irgendwie Dualboot machen musst oder direkt ins kalte Wasser geworfen wirst.
Also zum Anfang
einfach nur eine VM und gut ist. So, aber was sagt der meine Benchmarks hier?
Meine Benchmarks, Benchmarken noch.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was rauskommt. Also ich meine, eigentlich kann ich es mir schon denken. .NET am schnellsten, gefolgt von Rust
und dann Go hintendran.
Also in diesem einen speziellen Fall jetzt. Was macht der da eigentlich so lange?
So, ja, guck mal. Boah, alter, was ein Unterschied, man!
Guckt euch das mal an. Okay, also unser Benchmark ist 100 Funktionsaufrufe, die nichts machen, ja. Also
von einem Funktionsaufruf 100, nicht einer.
100 Funktionsaufrufe von .NET nach .NET sind natürlich abfuck schnell.
28,8 für Nanosekunden. Das ist mega schnell, ja.
Das ist aber auch klar.
Gefolgt von Rust. Call in Rust, also die haben ein super, super C-Interface, was einfach funktioniert, ohne viel Overhead.
Nur
125 Nanosekunden für 100 Aufrufe. Das ist auch im Prinzip
Mix, eigentlich. Und jetzt kommt Go. Go braucht einfach mal, sehe ich das richtig, 8 Millisekunden.
Also
8114 Nanosekunden.
Jetzt muss ich ein Video machen auf YouTube, dass Go stirbt, ja.
Blazingly fast. Rust is destroying Go.
Go will be dead soon. Oder irgendwas in der Regel. Wir brauchen noch ein bisschen mehr, mehr Klick.
Wir brauchen, wir brauchen Klickbait. Go is dead. Here is why.
Mikrosekunden. Ja, ja, Mikrosekunden. Wir sind hier in Bananosekunden.
How Golang is destroying your performance. Genau.
Mikrosekunden, nicht Millisekunden. Ja, ich hab mich vertan. Kann man auch mal durcheinander kommen. Also
.NET, logischerweise in dem Fall das schnellste. 28 Nanosekunden. Rust
125 Nanosekunden. Würde ich sagen, das ist so wirklich, da kannst du ohne Problem nach Rust callen. Und hier 8 Mikrosekunden.
Nicht, dass 8 Mikrosekunden schnell wäre, aber es ist um Größenordnungen
langsamer als Rust. .NET steht ja eigentlich gar nicht zur Auswahl, weil die WebRTC-Libraries für .NET,
da gibt, es gibt SipSorcery für .NET, das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Aber ich finde, dem fehlen noch ein paar Features, dass man sie komplett
so gut benutzen kann, wie die Go-Library zum Beispiel. Und die Rust-Library weiß ich noch nicht.
Das ist ein Nachbau von der Go-Library, die ich verwenden will, aber ich weiß nicht, wie feature-complete die schon ist.
Mach die Übung mal anders, mit Rust als Base und import C-Sharp.
Also, von Rust nach Go wird mehr oder weniger genauso sein.
Aber von Rust nach C-Sharp ist gar nicht so einfach möglich,
weil C-Sharp braucht eine .NET-Runtime, die läuft.
Das heißt, ich müsste quasi eine .NET-Runtime in Rust hosten, was sicherlich geht.
Ja, du kannst AOT machen, aber ich erzähle euch, wie es die ganze Zeit gewesen ist.
Du bräuchst quasi, du musst quasi eine .NET-Runtime in Rust hosten. Ich glaube, das will man nicht machen.
Seit den letzten,
seit .NET 6, aber eher seit .NET 7 und noch spannender wird es mit .NET 8. .NET 8 kommt ja demnächst,
quasi raus.
Da unterstützen die ja auch Ahead-of-Time-Compilation, also im Prinzip das, was
so ein Compiler macht.
Normalerweise halt irgendwas native ausführbares rauswerfen. Dann kann man
auch, Moment, da gibt es wirklich was, da kann man dann auch direkt Funktionen daraus aufrufen.
Nee, das ist was anderes. Das ist was anderes. Das ist Rust zu
IR-Kompilieren, was dann in .NET laufen kann. Das ist auch Six-Head, dass es sowas gibt,
aber das ist andersrum.
Das ist Rust in .NET. Wir wollen ja .NET von echtem Rust aufrufen.
So, jetzt müssen wir aber nochmal,
was ist IR-Intermediate? Also das ist quasi IL.
IL und IR ist das, ist das, ist das gleiche quasi.
Bin ich jetzt blöd?
Ja, also IR und IL ist das gleiche im Endeffekt. Das ist nicht direkt
ausführbar von deinem Rechner, aber ausführbar von der .NET-Runtime. Also C-Sharp kompiliert ja auch nicht direkt in
ein Binary, was du ausführen kannst, sondern C-Sharp kompiliert in Bytecode,
den .NET ausführen kann. Und wenn du in den C-Sharp-Binary startest, dann ist es in Wirklichkeit sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr
so, dass erst mal
.NET gestartet wird und .NET startet dann ein C-Sharp,
liest dann das
CLR, IR oder IL ein, je nachdem wie man es nennt und führt das aus.
Und dort ist es so, dass quasi
Rust zu IL umgewandelt wird und IL kann dann von der .NET-Runtime ausgeführt werden.
Das ist halt echt schon richtig sick, Seth. Ich wüsste nicht genau, wozu das...
Ich meine, ja, um Rust-Libraries in C-Sharp zu verwenden, aber es funktioniert noch nicht alles.
Aber cool, dass das funktioniert.
So, jetzt haben wir unser Benchmark-Zeug hier am Start. Das werde ich jetzt gerade einfach mal wieder auskommentieren.
Und wir gucken uns mal an, wie man in Rust ein Struct baut und das Struct zurückgibt
an C-Sharp. Also, Call Rust 2 brauchen wir jetzt noch.
Das legen wir jetzt hier auch mal an.
Ich prophezeie, dass es etwas einfacher wird als in Go, weil Rust-C-Interop ist ziemlich gut in der Regel.
Aber Rust hat schon .NET-Libraries, oder nicht? Nee, Rust ist Rust und Rust ist nicht .NET normalerweise.
Hast du einen coolen, vielleicht auch leichten Weg mit Rust? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber ich glaube, man muss ganz schön masochistisch sein, veranlagt sein, mit Rust Windows-UI-Anwendungen bauen zu wollen.
Das ist einfach nur so mein Bauchgefühl dazu.
Blazingly fast written in Rust. Musst du jetzt aber auch bei allen deinen Projekten dabeischreiben.
Also, okay, wie macht man... Es geht ja schon mal los, Leute. Wie man überhaupt einen Struct in Rust macht.
Struct. Okay, so...
Nice, Max, super.
Ich glaube, so weit wärt ihr wahrscheinlich auch schon gekommen, oder?
Okay, aber...
Wie geht es weiter? Rust, Struct.
FFI, suchen wir mal danach.
Ja, Complex Data Tabs and Rust FFI, genau.
Okay, also, Inamstruct, hier, RepR, RepR, RepR, C.
Okay, das ist so ein typisches Rust-Ding. Das können wir copy-pasten.
Das ist eines der Gründe, warum Rust echt nicht schön zu lesen ist.
Pupp, Pupp
ist quasi was wie Public. Public Ausschreiben ist outdated, overrated. Also machen wir hier mal das gleiche. Session,
Name. Okay, wir fangen einfach an. Wir machen wieder das gleiche.
Hier, Client ID.
Und...
Nee, komm, wir sind A, B, heißt es jetzt. So, UINT, nee, Moment.
Int. Moment, es ist Rust. Da ist es U64 einfach nur, gell?
Ja, es ist Rust. Und hier noch mal, eh noch ein Bool oder so. Ja, okay, Build.
Es bildet noch. Und jetzt, Return.
Tja, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das
So? A, 1, 2, 3.
B, Moment.
B, Schuhe.
Ne? Ein Semikolon vielleicht?
Ja.
So? Hm.
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Ah, ja, ja.
Ach so, weil ich kein Return-Type angegeben habe.
Rust-Return-Type ist so, gell? Ja, okay, ist schon besser, schon besser.
Übrigens, ich hab's verkackt. Ich hab's in der falschen Funktion gemacht. Das muss hier unten rein.
Format.
Okay, und das funktioniert jetzt. Moment, das funzt.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie das, wie das zurückkommt in, in .NET.
Wir brauchen, wir müssen das mal kurz ein bisschen ändern.
Hier, Session, Rename, Rename, Session, äh, Go.
Session, Rust. So, U, Int, und dann haben wir hier einen Bool.
Und ja, A, B, wie's heißt, ist egal.
Jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das, das ist ja die Basics. Das sind einfach nur Values zurückgeben.
Und unser Ziel ist ja hier auch noch einen String zurückzugeben und sowas. Das wird dann schon ein bisschen komplizierter.
Call Rust 2 zurück, bekommen wir eine Session.
Okay, Call Rust 2.
Session gleich.
Session A
und
Session B. Und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das funzt, was da rauskommt. 1, 2, 3 und True.
True, Lulw. Ja, das funzt. Okay, das,
das war schon ein bisschen einfacher als in Go an der Stelle.
Weil Rust ist deutlich besser, also wir brauchen kein C, Go und C, Struct definieren und sowas.
Das ist einfacher. So, und jetzt kommt ein String. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie das funzt.
Kann ich, kann ich einfach sagen, String, das geht doch im Leben nicht, oder? Wenn ich hier einfach sage, ich returne ein String.
Keck weh.
Okay, jetzt kommt Rust-Gedöns.
Warum kann ich einem Struct String kein String zuweisen?
Weil man irgendwie sagen muss, Pass as String oder sowas. Ich erinnere mich dunkel.
From String, from to String. Wo ist der Unterschied dazwischen?
Aber das habe ich schon mal, das habe ich schon mal gesehen in Rust, ja.
Das kompiliert zwar, aber das wird nicht funktionieren.
Das wird, das wird so nicht funktionieren, weil die Rust-String-Repräsentation ganz anders ist.
Als das, was sich C-Sharp vorstellt.
Aber wir können es mal ausprobieren. Wir stellen uns einfach mal wieder doof und sagen, das ist ein String, okay.
So, das wird nicht funzen.
Es crasht sogar.
Crasht es? Crasht es wirklich?
Ja, es crasht.
Okay, es crasht, es crasht komplett.
Macht einfach gar nichts.
Also das funzt so definitiv nicht.
Aber das habe ich auch schon gedacht.
Ich brauche, ich brauche ein c-string oder sowas. Oder einen, oder einen character array oder sowas.
Wir gucken mal in die Hilfe von Rust. Ach hier guck mal.
Const c, Const c char.
Hat er importiert?
hat er importiert?
konsti
das geht natürlich nicht
kann man sowas machen wie pointer?
es pointer
aber das ist kein null
terminierter string
das
das kann man sagen wie into pointer
oder so
rust magic
das funzt nicht
was ist konst
konst u8
das ist jetzt quasi ein byte array
kompiliert
ich bin mal gespannt was jetzt
in C sharp rauskommt
es crasht einfach wieder
ok
es crasht
ok dann probieren wir was anderes
dann probieren wir was anderes
int pointer
das sollte jetzt nicht mal crashen
es crasht immer noch
ich habe die
go session bearbeitet
ah
ich bin ein kack noob
ok das funzt
also
hier gibt es den int pointer
hier kriege ich den int pointer
zurück
und was kann ich mit dem int pointer jetzt machen
sicherlich nicht als string parsen
oder
marshall
pointer to string
bam geht nicht
pointer
to
ey das funzt nicht
das ergibt aber auch sinn dass das nicht funktioniert
weil rust strings sind ja nicht null terminated
und sonst wie das
das klappt nicht
mut u8 haben wir auch noch
nicht dass das was ändert oder so
ne ne das funzt nicht
ok also ich muss da irgendwie mit
c string hantieren
c string new
c unwrap
das klingt sehr rust style
machen wir es mal sowas hier
let str gleich
c string
was
new
und jetzt hier sowas wie
kack w oder so
und an der stelle dann
hier machen wir auch wieder char
c char
und an der stelle dann str
ok ne funzt nicht
warum
expected const
found
ah nochmal unwrap
unwrap
unwrap muss da oben hin
into raw
klingt doch sinnvoll oder
s pointer
zack kompiliert
run
oh
das lookt nicht korrekt
das lookt gar nicht korrekt
das sieht nach
wurde gefreed aus
das ergibt
auch sinn dass es nicht funktioniert
weil rust
wird das hier wahrscheinlich verwerfen
sobald die funktion zu ende ist
jetzt ist die große preisfrage
wie kriege ich rust dazu
dass es das
überlebt
wir gucken uns mal die hilfe von c
string in rust an
global definieren
ne ne ne
extracting a raw pointer
s pointer
also eins kann man rust ja meistens nicht vorwerfen
dass uns zu wenig docs haben
aber dass ich nicht durchblicke
ist schon wieder
s pointer
ja so schlau bin ich auch
safety
ich muss
ich muss dem ding jetzt
bei rust ist es so
rust ist super pingelig
was lifetime von objekten angeht
und rust ist schlau genug und weiß
am ende dieses dings
normalerweise müsste ich jetzt sowas machen
ja irgendwie und also rust
logisch da muss man dann und mut oder so
komisches zeug da vormachen
aber das also
dass ich rust sage
ich möchte
quasi das ownership
heißt das bei rust übertragen an den der aufruft
aber ich weiß nicht wie das funktioniert
geht mit nem apostrophe
mit was
so
alter rust macht mich fertig
ne ne das kanns nicht sein oder
examples
den hat man schon
weg
wenn du willst übergibst du einfach noch den c string noch mal als
feldinstruct
ich übergebe doch das
hier
oder du meinst hier c string
ja aber das wird doch
da nicht so funktionieren wie ich mir das gedacht
hab oder
so
nee its not ffe safe
das wird nicht funktionieren so
siehste
crasht einfach direkt ne ne ne ne
so funzt das nicht
ähm
wir sind glaube ich
im richtigen weg
das ist glaube ich garnicht so verkehrt
vielleicht muss ich auch einfach sagen
mut
hier oben anstatt konst
in c sharp muss das in den session daten
zu string geändert werden nee muss es nicht
ich bekomme nen in pointer
und den wandle ich dann selbst
in den string um das muss auch funktionieren
ok das geht nicht warum
weil
type differs in
expected raw pointer
und found raw pointer
konst
jetzt kommt richtig krasses
nice backseating hier an start
und das soll jetzt funktionieren
da hab ich so meine zweifel
dass das funzt
und
funzt nicht
ich will dem sagen dass er hier
ownership übertragen soll
ok wie geht das
was haben wir denn sonst noch hier
from raw
into raw
consumes
the c string and transfer
ownership of the string to the c
caller das ist das
was ich wahrscheinlich will
into
into raw
das gibt ein mut
c char
was ja auch durchaus ok ist ich kann ja da drin rum
sauen wie ich will mach ich aber nicht aber könnte ich
ok lässt sich
kombinieren und jetzt und jetzt
post champ
post champ ich finde meine
emotes grad nicht
post champ time
funzt easy
kaum macht man es richtig
easy as fuck
easy
hat funktioniert
also so funzt das in rust
c string
moment
und dann sagt man
das ist go
into raw
so was haben wir denn sonst noch
the pointer
which this function returns
must be returned to rust
and
reconstituted using
c string from
raw
so
Das ist schon ein See, quasi. Ohne was dazwischen.
Zwei Sekunden, vier Gigabyte RAM, Alter.
Mich würde nicht wundern, wenn irgendeine IDE abgekackt ist, jetzt, weil er zu viel RAM sich geschnappt hat.
Halbe Forkbomb ist das schon, ohne sich zu forken. Gut.
Also, was müssen wir machen?
The pointer which is found must be returned to Rust and re-configured using C-String from raw to be properly deallocated.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das stimmt, was die da sagen.
Wir machen jetzt da einfach mal ein String draus, weil dann wissen wir ja, dass der automatisch freet.
Und jetzt sollten wir kein Memory Leak mehr haben.
Wir haben kein Memory Leak mehr.
Alles perfectly fine.
Na, oder vielleicht doch so ein kleines Memory Leak vielleicht.
Ne, wir haben kein Memory Leak.
Aber, aber vielleicht doch ein kleines.
Genau, C-Sharp macht wieder free.
Profile ist doch... Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gerade nicht, wie gescheit, weil...
...mein Rider ist irgendwie der Meinung, Debugger funktioniert nicht.
Warum auch immer, vielleicht geht er jetzt.
Nö.
Obwohl ich's mit... er versucht mein...
...ihr .NET Location, ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, der soll mein .NET verwenden und nicht das falsche .NET.
Ja, ist es nicht!
Ist es eben nicht!
Das Ganze ist ein .NET 8 Projekt und er zeigt's auch hier an, dass es .NET 8 ist.
Aber Rider ist der Meinung, ne...
...ist es nicht. Guck hier, .NET 8, .NET Version 8.
Ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung, ergibt keinen Sinn, ich glaub...
...ich glaube fast, das ist ein Bug in Rider, was wir hier haben.
.Memory.
So, und jetzt lesen wir mal weiter, was hier steht.
Ja, okay, hier.
Specifically, one should not use the standard C3 function to deallocate the string.
Das ist schon mal falsch, was wir da gerade machen.
Failure to call CString from raw will lead to a memory leak.
The C-Site must not modify the length of the string?
Ja, okay.
Also müssen wir noch das hier machen.
Bedeutet im Endeffekt auch, so dass wir kein Memory leaken, brauche ich noch eine Funktion, die nennen...
Ups.
...brauche ich noch eine Funktion, die nennen wir jetzt einfach mal hier, ähm...
...pre-stril oder so.
Und da rufen wir jetzt auf...
...CString from raw, okay, hier Pointer rein.
Und dann wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, äh, okay, Rust.
Rust, geht das so?
Achso, das muss in den Unsave-Block.
Ist ja fast wie in .NET hier.
Öh, das ist nicht einfach.
Ich will das so haben.
Warum, warum sieht der Unsave-Block hier so kacke aus?
Ah, dann machen wir es so.
Okay, und jetzt ist das, jetzt ist das safe.
Da muss ich das aber noch dazu aufrufen, und zwar...
...würde ich sagen...
...muss ich dann hier noch...
...was reinpacken, und zwar...
...nicht call Rust, sondern...
...pre-stril...
...int Pointer...
...äh...
...so, und wenn ich jetzt das Memory-Leak vermeiden will...
...sage ich interop pre-stril...
...und gebe da Session meinen...
...nee, nein, ich mein String, das funktioniert ja so jetzt nicht.
Ja, okay, jetzt ergibt das Sinn, jetzt müssen wir es nämlich wirklich selbst machen.
int Pointer...
Ich hab schon wieder das Falsche editiert, man.
Ich hab schon wieder die Go-Session editiert.
int Pointer, wir benennen das übrigens mal gescheit, sonst kann ich es gar nicht mehr nicht merken.
Client Name, so.
Und jetzt sollte das Memory-Leak auch wieder weg sein.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Da liegt nix mehr.
Ich mein, es ist offensichtlich, vorher hatten wir 4 Gigabyte pro 2 Sekunden und jetzt haben wir nix.
Okay.
.memory hab ich noch nie ausprobiert, kann man .memory vielleicht installieren über die Toolbox?
.trace haben wir.
.net performance profiler.
Geht das damit auch?
Hab ich noch nie, hab ich noch nie verwendet.
Zeigt der mir auch die Memory-Usage?
Eigentlich, ohne Scheiß...
Eigentlich fucks mich übelst ab, dass der Ryder-Debugger nicht geht.
Warum geht da Ryder? Okay, ich hab ne Idee, woran das liegt.
Wir gehen jetzt mal hier auf Build & Tool Sets.
Es ist eindeutig richtig eingestellt.
Kann ich das systemweit speichern, einfach?
Jetzt funzt's.
Shit, warum benutzt der? Alter, was ist das für ein Kack?
Warum benutzt der so ein alles outdatedes .net?
Versteh ich nicht.
Es ist irgendein Bug.
Hier ist alles richtig eingestellt.
Nee, der Ryder benutzt die Runtime, die ich ja ausgewählt hab normalerweise,
aber anscheinend macht's das in dem Fall nicht, weil's irgendwie verbuggt ist.
Was ziemlich suckt.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Das sind doch die richtigen Settings, oder was?
Ich wüsste nicht, was hier dran...
Weil die Runtime auch stimmt.
Wir können hier nochmal die Runtime hinzufügen.
maxhome.net
.net
Custom. So, Apply.
Ah, jetzt geht's!
Jetzt geht's.
Glaub ich zumindest.
Oder?
Ja.
Memory.
Haben die nicht sowas?
Chat Gil.
Ich benutze den Debugger in Ryder sehr selten.
Haben die nicht so eine Anzeige wie in Visual Studio Code,
wo man einfach sehen kann live, was das für Memory verwendet?
Anscheinend nicht, oder?
Ja, stimmt auch wieder.
Aber ist doch blöd, dass das nicht eingebaut ist, oder?
Das ist dann tatsächlich eine Sache, wo ich sagen würde,
da ist Visual Studio Code angenehmer.
Äh, nicht Visual Studio Code, äh, Visual Studio angenehmer.
Auf die drei Dots bei Debuggen.
Du meinst hier, oder wo?
Oder da?
Profile with Sampling.
Ah.
Excellent.
So, und wo seh ich jetzt den, den RAM-Verbrauch?
Erst wenn ich's wieder geschlossen hab, oder...
...seh ich das live?
Da gibt's doch eins für Memory.
Echt?
Snapshot?
Ey, das ist aber nicht die Memory-Size, oder?
Äh, boah, da blinke ich nicht durch, das mit zu high IQ jetzt.
Das mir, das ist mir massified zu high IQ, äh.
Was ist jetzt CPU? Ja, ich hätte gerne Memory.
Das massify IQ Zeug hier.
Okay, stoppen wir mal.
Profile with? Profile running process? Profile...
Sampling? Memory!
Ja, sowas such ich!
Genau.
Excellent.
Genau das hab ich gesucht.
Dass man sieht, wie viel Speicher das Ding verbraucht.
Man sieht, wir haben absolut null Memory-Leaks.
Gar nix.
Null Memory-Leaks.
Es ist einfach die ganze Zeit...
...immer auf 43,59.
So, wir können das, wir können das Ganze, Ganze nochmal...
...checken, indem wir sagen...
...wir lassen das, wir lassen das Free mal weg, aber...
...wir machen...
...wenn man in Sleep kurz rein...
...von...
...einer Millisekunde...
...das ist...
...jetzt hatten wir es mehrfach drauf, dass es nicht sich komplett in die...
...in die, in die Quere kommt, ja.
So, und jetzt sagen wir...
...Profile with Memory.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet...
...ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass das...
...irgendwie...
Es geht hoch, ja es geht hoch, guckt Leute.
Es geht hoch.
Langsam, weil eine Millisekunde Sleep dazwischen...
...und eine Millisekunde ist verdammt viel...
...wenn der Millionen Aufrufe pro Sekunde macht normalerweise.
Ja.
Jetzt sieht man, dass ein Memory-Leak drin ist.
Guckt, es geht immer ein bisschen weiter hoch.
Nice, nice.
Okay, heute, das ist wirklich nice...
...dass ihr wusstet, wo das ist, weil...
...ähm...
...wir können aber sagen, Timespan...
...Brom...
...Microseconds...
...jede Mikrosekunde...
...einfach, bam.
Profile Memory.
Oh ja, guckt Leute.
Jetzt geht's steil.
Die Speicher aus Gigabyte.
1,2 Gigabyte, 1,4, 1,6, 1,7.
Ja, jetzt wird Memory-Leaked as fuck.
Jetzt hat man's, jetzt hat man's wirklich gut gesehen.
So, und jetzt machen wir das Free rein.
Jetzt machen wir das Free rein.
Aber Chat, da habt ihr mal was Gutes gezeigt.
Das wusste ich gar nicht, dass es das gibt.
Das ist mega praktisch dafür.
Rider ist einfach echt beste.
So, guckt, und jetzt kein Memory-Leak mehr.
Es bleibt einfach bei 44 MB Memory total used.
Excellent, Leute.
Excellent, excellent.
Okay.
So, und was lernen wir daraus?
Okay, wir machen jetzt nochmal einen abschließenden...
...wie krieg ich denn das hier minimiert, so?
Jetzt machen wir nochmal einen abschließenden Vergleich...
...zu diesem ganzen Campbell.
Wir schmeißen das hier raus.
Wir sagen...
...Duster wird einmal aufgerufen.
Dann wird Interop...
...Call Rust einmal aufgerufen.
Interop Call Rust 2.
Und Interop Call Go.
So, jetzt lassen wir uns einmal noch Benchmark-Ergebnisse...
...generaten.
Zum Vergleich...
Das kommt weg.
Also, den .NET-Vergleich, den machen wir mal wieder raus.
Den braucht eigentlich niemand an der Stelle.
Wir wissen, dass .NET schnell ist.
Von .NET zu .NET.
Ja, also hier Run.
Gucken wir uns das nochmal abschließend an.
Go 2.
Und...
...Run Rust 2.
Wobei wir da...
...tatsächlich noch einen Free machen müssen.
Der in Go unter der Haube passiert.
Aber das ist ja nicht schlimm.
So.
Und jetzt können wir nochmal den Benchmark laufen lassen.
Und uns freuen...
...dass wir eine tolle Benchmark-Ausgabe kriegen.
Glaube ich zumindest, dass ich nichts falsch gemacht habe.
Oh, doch.
Run, Run Rust.
Fehlt noch das normale...
...Call Rust.
So, okay.
Wenn man jetzt noch richtig schreiben könnte, wäre perfekt.
Gibt es überhaupt Go 2, ja?
Gibt es?
Go 2 macht das mit dem Struct.
So, ich bin mal gespannt.
Habst du da High IQ Stream heute?
Ja, stimmt schon.
Übrigens schön, dass so viele Leute wieder am Start sind.
Ich meine, das ist ja nicht selbstverständlich...
...dass quasi die ganze Zeit über 200 Leute zugucken...
...bei so einem Kram hier, ja?
Muss man beim Struct in Rust nicht auch die Namen anpassen...
...oder hattest du das schon gemacht?
Ne, warum brauche ich die Namen anpassen?
Was meinst du?
Du meinst, weil das in C Sharp...
...heißt...
...Session Rust und Session Go?
Das ist Wurscht.
Wichtig ist einfach nur, dass die...
...das Speicher-Layout das gleiche ist.
Ich könnte es auch ein...
...ich könnte es auch...
...Cacquait, QChat, Ajaja nennen.
Das Struct.
Vollkommen egal, wie das...
...wie das in C Sharp heißt.
A Client ID ist der Name auch egal.
Der Typ ist das Wichtige.
Also hauptsache, dass das Struct...
...denn das ist das richtige Memory-Layout.
Also dass es in Rust A und B heißt, ist vollkommen egal.
Wichtig ist, dass es ein Struct ist...
...dass als erstes ein Bool kommt...
...als zweites ein Int...
...als drittes ein String oder sowas.
Das muss stimmen in beiden Sprachen.
Wie das heißt, ist vollkommen egal.
Weil die...
...denn die Namen stehen dann irgendwo drinne.
Was der sich einfach merkt, ist...
...die Size von dem Struct...
...und wie er das dann quasi...
...casten muss in den eigentlichen Managed-Typ...
...vom...
...von der Speicher-Aufteilung her.
Ja, ich mag die Streams auch.
Ich meine, ich kann natürlich eben nicht immer...
...so Sachen aus dem Ärmel schütteln, ja.
Immer nur, wenn was ansteht.
So, ich bin mal gespannt, was bei den Benchmarks rauskommt.
Wobei, eigentlich bin ich nicht gespannt.
Wir wissen alle, was rauskommt.
Rust schneller.
Ja.
Um Längen schneller.
Guckt mal.
Also...
...die Funktion...
...hier...
...die pure Rust-Funktion aufrufen...
...ist einfach 124 Nanosekunden zu 8,5 Mikrosekunden.
Und hier ist...
Go braucht für die Geschichte mit dem Struct...
...18...
...Nanosekunden...
...18.000 Nanosekunden...
...ne, Moment.
18.000 Nanosekunden...
...also 18 Millisekunden, sehe ich das richtig?
Chat?
Ne, Mikrosekunden.
Mikrosekunden, nicht Millisekunden.
Meine Güte!
Boah!
Einheiten!
Keck, wait!
18 Mikrosekunden...
...und Rust braucht einfach nur 2.
Ist schon eine ganze Ecke schneller.
Und hier haben wir...
...und das dürfen wir nicht vergessen...
...hier haben wir 2 Calls...
...drinne.
Wir haben...
...in der...
...und es sind trotzdem schneller.
Wir haben 2 Calls.
Wir haben den...
...eigentlichen...
...Call zum Struct erzeugen...
...und wir haben den Call zum Free noch drinne.
Nimm mal String als Type und nicht Pointer.
Lass ihn Free callen.
Sollte schneller sein.
Ne.
Also, ja.
Vielleicht ist das...
...ein Ticken schneller.
Weil .NET das Free macht...
...und nicht Rust gecallt wird.
Aber...
...die Rust-Docs sagen explizit...
...man soll nicht Free callen, sondern...
...soll das zurück an Rust geben...
...und Rust soll es freeen.
Sonst Memory Leak.
Es ist...
...also du hast Recht, das ist schneller.
Aber wir können das ausprobieren.
Schade nix.
Wir können das ausprobieren.
Ich lass das...
...ich lass das mal weg.
Und wir ändern den hier zu String.
Wir haben ja gesehen...
...wir haben auch nahezu kein Memory Leak...
...und führen das Ganze nochmal...
...ööö...
...ja.
Jetzt sollte er schneller sein...
...aber wir haben potenziell ein Memory Leak.
Zumindest...
...sagen die Rust...
...sagt die Rust-Doku das...
...dass wir dann einen Memory Leak haben.
Wenn wir das nicht so machen.
Also Arduino plus Rust...
...hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Ich bin eher der ESP32-Enjoyer.
Und da ist Rust ja auch nur...
...sagen wir mal so...
...sehr rudimentär.
Vieles geht ja in Rust noch nicht.
Ich glaube, Rust und WiFi...
...geht glaube ich auch noch nicht...
...auf dem...
...auf dem ESP32.
Ja, genau.
Das...
...das...
...genau deshalb denke ich auch.
Es kann ja auch möglich sein...
...dass Rust nicht einfach...
...den...
...das Memory...
...allocated...
...über die...
...das normale C-Malloc...
...sondern irgendwas eigenes macht.
Und dann bringt ja normales C-Free...
...an der Stelle ja auch wenig.
Wenn da noch Sachen nestet...
...irgendwie anderweitig allokiert sind...
...von denen nur Rust was weiß.
Also das ergibt schon Sinn.
Und dass das auch ein Memory-Leak hat...
...gehe ich auch von aus...
...aber es dürften wahrscheinlich...
...nur ein paar Bytes sein.
Über Unsafe sollte WLAN gehen.
Sofern man die...
...eingebauten...
...ESP-C-Sachen aufrufen kann aus Rust...
...dann vielleicht, ja.
Aber ehrlich gesagt...
...muss ich...
...muss ich sagen...
...Plattform-IO...
...und auch wenn da unter der Haube...
...C++ für den ESP32 ist...
...ist recht angenehm.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt...
...dass in dem Fall C++...
...und ich sag's nur ungern, ja...
...aber C++ für solche Sachen...
...angenehmer ist.
Rust plus...
...plus Arduino...
...gibt's da denn ein gutes Projekt für?
Wir hatten das...
...wir hatten das geschrieben.
Gibt's da ein gutes Projekt für?
Kannst mal schicken...
...vielleicht können wir uns das wirklich angucken.
So.
Leute, ich weiß nicht warum...
...aber das Ganze ist jetzt langsamer geworden...
...wenn wir C-Sharp freen lassen.
Okay?
Also es ist schneller...
...es ist schneller Rust freen zu lassen als...
...als C-Sharp freen zu lassen.
Okay?
Ah ja.
Meinetwegen...
...soll mir recht sein, okay.
Der Benchmark hier unten...
...ist aber für meine Sachen...
...eh nicht sonderlich relevant...
...weil die Funktion...
...die ich wirklich schnell in der Schleife aufrufe...
...ist nichts was Strings oder so returnt...
...sondern das returnt gar nichts.
Bekommt einfach nur nen...
...nen Pointer als Parameter übergeben...
...den es auch nicht selbst freen muss.
Also insofern ist das hier eigentlich für mich...
...die, die, der relevantere Benchmark...
...und da ist Rust meilenweit schneller.
.NET ist noch einen Ticken schneller...
...also .NET zu .NET ist logischerweise...
...schneller als .NET zu Rust...
...aber Rust ist um Welten schneller als Go.
Überrascht mich aber auch nicht...
...weil ich wusste dass C-Go langsam ist...
...und ich wollte einfach mal gucken...
...ob es mittlerweile besser geworden ist.
Ich würde sagen es ist besser geworden...
...aber es ist immer noch ziemlich...
...ziemlich lahm...
...wenn man Millionenfach das aufruft.
Wenn man das jetzt einfach nur...
...ein paar tausend mal aufruft oder so...
...drauf geschissen...
...da macht es ein bisschen Overhead auch nicht aus.
Aber wenn man das Millionenfach...
...pro Sekunde aufruft...
...dann macht es schon einiges aus.
Was ich übrigens auch nicht machen werde.
Also...
...also für meine Verhältnisse...
...könnte ich auch einfach...
...die Go Library verwenden...
...aber warum?
Ich meine...
...wir können...
...das machen wir dann...
...einmal nächsten Streams...
...da machen wir dann...
...WebRTC in Rust.
Sind auch Aufrufe von Go nach C langsam?
Ja, ja, auch...
Theoretisch sind die ein Ticken schneller...
...also früher war es so...
...Aufrufe von Go nach C...
...waren langsam...
...also auch langsamer als von anderen Sprachen...
...von anderer Sprache nach C...
...aber...
...in Go reinkollen von C aus...
...war nochmal eine Ecke langsamer.
Mittlerweile...
...mittlerweile ist es glaube ich...
...ungefähr gleich langsam.
Aber das ist auch langsam, ja...
...es ist vielleicht nicht ganz so langsam...
...wie von anderer Sprache zu Go...
...aber auch langsam.
Go hat mit...
...mit...
...den langsamsten Interop...
...mit anderen Sprachen...
...von allen Programmiersprachen...
...die es gibt.
Go an sich ist relativ flott...
...aber...
...was hier alles immer über irgendeinen C-Interface geht...
...da ist Go richtig langsam...
...was auch ein Problem ist...
...weil...
...die ganzen...
...Wrapper-Libraries für SQLite...
...oder für irgendwelche anderen Low-Level-Sachen...
...die sind potenziell in Go einfach arschlangsam...
...weil...
...C-Go langsam ist.
Also wenn man ordentlich Load drauf hat...
...und...
...also wenn man ordentlich Load drauf hat, ja...
...deswegen gibt es beispielsweise für SQLite...
...ein Projekt...
...das SQLite...
...transpiled nach Go...
...damit es native Go kompiliert werden kann...
...und nicht mit C-Function-Calls...
...weil SQLite unter ordentlich Last wohl...
...eine nicht zu unterschätzende Overhead hat...
...weil es sehr viele C-Calls macht in Go...
...weil SQLite halt eine C-Library ist.
Ja.
Also macht Probleme...
...Go ist schnell, solange man sich innerhalb von Go bewegt.
Und gibt es noch ein paar Examples?
Examples?
Plattform-IO.
Nice.
Ach, haben die das jetzt offiziell in Plattform-IO drin, ne?
Ne, das ist das ganz normale...
...ESP-IDF...
...Source...
...Main-AS.
Okay, ja, da haben sie Rapper um Sachen gebaut, okay.
Ja, also anscheinend kann man...
...in den Makro-Zeug...
...also anscheinend kann man auch...
...ESP mit Rust programmieren, aber ganz im Ernst, das...
...tue ich mir nicht an.
Jo.
Nice, Chat.
Fast drei Stunden...
...heute ganz schön lang gestreamt, heute Morgen drei Stunden, jetzt drei Stunden...
...das Maurice-Video.
Jo.
Chat.
Wir sind fertig für heute.
Schön, dass ihr am Start wart.
Guckt mal kurz, ob wir irgendjemand hosten können.
Ich hoffe, euch hat der Stream heute gefallen.
Wir haben...
...okay.
Hier haben wir...
...hier haben wir einen am Start, vielleicht hoste ich den, zeigt mal.
Der macht...
...ja, ja, Fake-Email.
...Devops plus Kubernetes.
Oh.
Der...
Ich glaube, der macht auch gerade seinen Stream aus, weil er Stream-Manager ist.
Na gut.
Dann nicht.
Okay, Chat.
Dann gehe ich auf.
Bis denn, macht's gut.
See you.
Winke-Winke.